Hello, hello, Ashley.
Dude, what the fuck?
This is the first.
All right, guys.
That is the first thing I read today for my playthrough.
What do you mean?
I am a good babysitter.
For those who don't know, I've told this story before a long
time ago.
But I actually, I took a, I did an after school club where
we learned how to be babysitters.
I've never done it before.
Like, I never took this practice into, like, reality.
but like but I paid uh $10 for this after school activity
because after after the whole duration of this activity that
we did after school um we had to take a test and then get a
uh a babysitter certificate so I have a babysitter
certificate which proves that I am, I can be a good
babysitter.
I've never babysat before, afterwards.
Like, afterwards, I may have never babysat, but I do have a
certificate.
So, that makes me more qualified than anybody else here.
Do you have a babysitter certificate?
I don't think so.
I pay $10 for this.
takes it okay i have i i don't know where it is because i
took this after school activity in middle school so so like
i don't even know where the fuck the babysitting certificate
is anymore um no thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you here's ten dollars for your expired certificate um
bacon thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you ashley's
beautiful I know that like Ashley is in good hands okay I
won't like it but like I wouldn't she's literally the
president's daughter like why the fuck would I like why
would you think that I cannot do it I am certified guys also
speaking of our clips didn't win the best clip guys you guys
lied to me so you know about our deal Wait, I just want you
guys to know none of our apex clips won the Best clips in
the apex tournament because apparently Unlike me when I said
don't raid her chat to vote Apparently Apparently other
streamers were campaigning to To their communities to vote
for their clips.
So like the clip that one where people were like what the
fuck look guys no no no it's good that we didn't raid
because now because because then people would be because
people would say we rigged it okay now we're not the ones
that rigged it guys it's good because then other people
would have said we rigged it they would be like of course
the vtuber rigged the the clip awards but we didn't so we're
good people
we did it so we're good people we did it so we're good
people we have dignity also we also you guys also promised
me something i was like if these clips don't win i swear to
fucking god We are the good guys.
We are the good guys.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They have no tastes in clips.
Shake my head.
Mario Doki needs to straw her babysitting seals for Ashley
tonight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We have the moral high ground.
Because I said no, no rigging.
We lost though.
Because I forgot.
I forgot about it.
It's like student council all over again.
people will campaign it's a thousand dollars
I forgot about that I forgot like if it's a vote on if it's
a popular vote people would campaign for it I forgot just
like politics anyway all right here we go resident evil 4
I've always wanted to um well i always wanted to finish this
game but like obviously um i don't want to go back and play
all the way to the beginning because of the original game
because like that was like a lot because that would require
me to to deal with og ashley who has one of the worst
fucking um npc pathways ever so so um because of my hatred
of Ashley's NPC movements and escort missions I've decided
to play the remake because at least I don't have to go
through the original Ashley and instead I can go through
with remake Ashley who apparently has better passing now so
I decided it for the sake of my sanity uh and not redoing
the entire fucking 70 of the game um i decided to do the
remake because at least like it'll still be new to me and
the pathing would not be as bad like i don't know i just
feel like ashley 2.0 was the way to go all right here we go
okay adjust the pattern until the pat where is the pattern
holy shit why is it so bright automatically Okay.
Why is it like maxed out?
D-Dragon, thank you for the Super Chat, thank you.
If you hate Ashley and any Resident Evil 4, then it's a
little skill issue.
Thank you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I won't say I hate her.
I just don't want her to exist.
That's different.
All right.
Let's see.
Just until the pattern is just...
barely visible okay then i guess this there you go uh here
you go uh adjust under until the image in the center is
barely visible if the image remains visible please check
your okay just until it is very oh my god if i make it so
bright then like it won't be scary anymore
I'm just saying if it's this bright then like it's not a
horror game it's just survival it's just action I can't be
scared because no monster's gonna show up when it's bright
like that's typical horror uh sassy thank you the super chat
thank you thank you we all agree of you nobody like Ashley
and OG Resident Evil 4 okay let's see I think this is fine
we'll just make it a little the just a little bit the
following me said okay nice adjust the i think that's good
uh see what okay i had to pretend to read it okay uh whoop i
did it i do not consent okay i do not have a cap do i have a
capcon id if you do not have a capcon that has been linked
to the platform id that you can check please select i do not
have have a what what the fuck is it okay I should have read
this uh in the company's account service Capcon ID why does
every game have an account now like it's over she's not
reading the terms of service no okay um all right guys what
is the Capcon ID do I no idea but I hate it okay don't think
I have one.
I'm just gonna hide the screen just in case like it requires
like personal information.
I'll just write, I don't have one.
Your play data can be viewed on, why do I need my play date
data?
They will be sent to the RE net whenever you select quick
game from the pause.
But I don't, the game has an auto save feature.
Okay.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
All right, that's cool.
I love it when things don't matter.
All right.
So Capcom ID does not matter, guys.
That's what we learn.
All right, start game.
Ooh, loud.
A new extra game is available to download mercenaries.
Oh, but it's free.
No.
Do I need it?
I don't really care.
Wait, can I, like, buy skins for Leon?
Online store.
Yes.
Are you cosmetics?
All right, let's see.
What the fuck is this Bunda?
Oh my god, wait.
is Leon and Ashley okay guys do we need to be immersed I
just need how much how much immersion do you guys want like
this is very important to how this game is gonna be how much
immersion do you guys want what do you mean by that I mean
I'm looking at this cosmetics right now this is question.
Do you want immersion or... Okay, you guys want...
Okay, I won't buy anything.
Hunjoys, thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
The Nyaya clip is number one in my mind.
Yeah, but it's not a winning clip.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Fine.
We won't buy any of the Leon costumes.
We won't... There's literally one where... Wait, is this one
where it's like Baldur's Gate-esque?
There is one where you can see his chest.
Guys, it's tempting.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Guys, I don't know.
Check out.
Guys, there's a 25% off for shirtless Leon.
Come on.
Wait, is this like goth?
What the fuck?
There's a goth, Ashley?
Okay, guys, but there's, like, goth Ashley, though.
Actually, you know what?
You know what?
I'm getting the goth, Ashley.
I'm getting...
We're getting that.
Because no matter what, we don't really care about what
Ashley looks like.
So might as well enjoy the ride.
Enjoy the ride of Ashley being goth.
It makes sense why she's, like, in this village.
Like, she wanted to get away from the president, like her
dad.
Alright, I won't make Leon immersive, because this other
skin, he doesn't really look like Leon.
He's just, it's just bald, like, you know that vampire dude
that everybody likes in Baldur's Gate?
Like, he basically looks like that.
And, like, um, this might be a super hot take, but I really
don't care about that guy.
I don't really give a fuck about...
I don't even know his name.
So, like, I think it might be a super hot take.
Because, like, I swear everybody's obsessed over him.
I think it's the accent.
I honestly think it's not what he looks like.
It's literally, like, the accent.
It's always the accent.
Okay, I need to restart the game.
Alright, don't worry.
We're putting Goth Ashley in here.
Close the game, please.
Zachary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Make this have all the cheese possible.
All right, guys.
I am restarting this real fast, guys.
Just to make sure.
Just to make sure we have what we want.
All right.
Resident Evil 4.
I swear.
It is mostly like Tumblr guy.
He's the new Tumblr guy.
And there's always a pattern.
with tumblr guys like the like the sexy man tumblr guys they
they usually have a british accent
all right obtain costumes i already miss og guys i know
there's people who did not like ashley's newest cost like
the remake costume don't pretend don't here you go all right
we're gonna Ashley.
Oh my I like how this is casual Ashley.
Like this is what she wears.
Casually.
Alright.
This is gonna be Ashley now.
Can I confirm this?
Alright.
Let's see.
How do I confirm that this is my Ashley?
Oh I guess it's like scene.
Scene girl.
It's more like Scene girl punk Ashley.
Alright, and then...
Can I confirm?
Did I confirm her?
Uh...
Alright, let's see.
I mean, it'll make me feel less bad about her like getting
kidnapped.
Wrong menu?
Wait, how do I...
How do I make her my Ashley?
This is my Ashley now.
I don't want to rescue Oh when I start the game Okay You can
now change care Oh here it is The Ashley fun Joy thank you
for the super chat Thank you Thank you Look just remember
Joy wanted this Joy wanted this Guys
Okay Yeah My Ashley Oh no hot topic Got to Ashley's
wardrobe.
Thank you, let's see, for chat, JL.
Thank you.
This is our Ashley now.
We all paid for this default, please.
It's too late.
I paid money for this, Ashley.
Please, I beg you.
Guys, it'll make us feel bad when she dies.
Guys, there's a reason why.
I paid for this, Ashley.
guilt okay so i feel less guilt what the fuck is this jacket
though okay here we go we're fine all right new game i'm not
doing hard because this is survival and the the thing i hate
the most about survival horror is the is the ammo
consumption so like i've decided that like i do not like
Like trying to find ammo.
I really hate finding ammo.
I hate item management.
No, I've always told you guys.
I hate item management the most.
Out of difficulties.
What do you mean?
I hear the game perfectly fine.
They just chop the guy's head up.
Where is the sound?
September 30th, 1998.
Today, I'll never forget.
Okay.
Audio, though.
Ways it up.
That night, Raccoon City was wiped out thanks to the
bio-weapons created by umbrella.
Somehow I made it out, but too many others weren't so lucky.
Oh, no.
I was asked later to join a top-secret government program.
Is that better now, guys?
I thought that I had a choice.
That's right.
You never have a choice.
Damn,
why aren't you buff?
You look like Captain America, pre-Captain America.
This time, it can be different.
It has to.
Hey, it looks like a happy time, Leon.
Don't worry.
That's gonna happen in a Resident Evil game.
That's not my Ashley.
But who the fuck is this girl?
Who's she?
Not my Ashley.
The chief gave the orders himself.
Help him, he said.
I'm sure your boys didn't come all the way out here to roast
marshmallows.
Oh, wait.
Sound guy's here.
Sound guy, what do you think?
Maybe he did.
You have a strange sense of humor.
I'm going to let you in on a little secret.
Just between us.
A lot of people have gone missing around here.
And it's been that way for a while now.
Should be just another day in the office, right?
Hmm.
I mean, last week there was a search for some missing
hikers.
I'm sure you're...
Missing hikers?
Look, the hikers are not important.
Are they the president's daughter?
I don't think so.
So...
Ashley is like worth 20 missing hikers.
Nature calls, huh?
I'll be right back.
The president's missing hiker.
The hiking guide.
Okay, the president's hiking guide is worth like half an
Ashley.
The president needs to hike.
I'll look I'll boost it up a little
Bro Are you watching him pee?
That's fucked up Oh Oh bro Did you pee on a corpse?
Bro
We are too No not me I looked away I respect a man Van's
privacy if he needs to pee.
He sure is taking his time.
Did he fall in?
Better go and take a look.
Yes, you Leon.
You should go look instead of me.
Yes, the guy that doesn't know this place.
You go on first.
I know, he's in the forest.
Fall into what exactly?
Oh wait, I can move now.
Chapter 1.
okay you now change colored costumes and accessories and the
extras all right let's look at the sound the audio okay
voice volume all right voice is already boosted up okay
that's unfortunate
all right uh a lower like a lower like bgm and like sound
effects and then boost up the regular more i don't know
sound guys still up i don't know if sound guys still still
here but i think that's gonna work okay graphics uh let's
see performance display i need to get if there is motion
blur i need to get that shit off uh is there motion blur in
this game guys okay camera wobble god no turn the camera
wobble for character movement no i hate that no camera oh
okay mouse sensitivity i'm gonna turn that low already uh
detail aim when aiming okay controls it's in graphics where
full hd uh performance well there's that's it oh wait there
it is Okay, I just need to scroll.
Okay, motion blur off.
Alright, guys, sorry.
Technical stuff right now to make this a good experience for
all of us.
Shadow, you know what, we're fine.
Let's just hope our PC can handle this.
I swear to God.
Alright, we should be good.
Alright, did it save?
Ooh, subtitle size.
Large, because we're blind as fuck.
I'm just gonna make sure everything's saved.
Motion blur off.
There we go.
Oh, is the FPS capped?
No, we don't need that.
Alright, that's good.
Oh!
I don't like that.
I knew I should have fucking made this brighter.
But I should have thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Chapter one.
To wash a dokey bird.
I knew it.
I knew I should have made the fucking screen brighter.
Oh.
This is way too dark.
Don't like this.
I don't fucking like this Ashley where are you They really
do I don't understand why they put motion blur in games Yeah
I'm reaching the super chat Thank you thank you I guess it's
for like console To hide the low frames and stuff But like
That should be off on default Oh hey there's a deer free
food
Oh okay that's it Alright I'll pack one for the ride Oh oh
crouches e what the fuck is controller okay what the okay i
need to know what is control
command ashley okay we're gonna we're gonna put this as
control and command ashley is e like like that okay i swear
is there another control toggle HUD what okay that's on the
menu okay mayhem mode what what the fuck is mayhem mode okay
I guess well I guess apparently this is very important so I
guess I guess we'll put this back to here because it
conflicts with mayhem mode whatever the fuck mayhem mode is
like oh it's mercenaries only okay yeah okay back to we're
gonna change that back then because that's dumb i can't i
cannot handle it i can actually does not deserve this at
that point actually actually you are not important enough
for this where is it where where the fuck is it where's the
where's control Ashley where are you confirm menu reset zoom
mayhem mode where the fuck did Ashley go I went past it okay
Ashley control command Ashley there you go command Ashley
okay you're gonna be e and then you're going to be control
because that is dumb as fuck okay there we go there you go
uh control e crouch stand and evade evade used to have been
bound to same action return return without applying no can i
just get rid of this oh shit uh oh shit uh delete uh Where's
my...
I don't have a delete button.
Fuck!
Okay, I need to grab my other keyboard.
I apparently don't have a delete button on my fucking 60%.
Do I have a delete button on this one?
Where the fuck is delete?
Alright!
Where's my other keyboards?
I don't have a delete button on this keyboard, too?
This is a mess.
Okay.
It's a, guys, I don't have a delete, guys, I don't have a
keyboard that has a delete button.
This is so bad.
Okay, this is awkward.
We'll just make this E.
That should be fine.
All right, good.
You guys are smart.
This is why I have you guys here.
You can make decisions for me.
All right, we should be fine.
Good.
good oh thank god we're figuring this out together all right
knock knock hello are you in here police officer were you
trying to find the toilet even though we saw you pee outside
oh i don't like this oh i don't like this oh i do not like
this at all oh
Um, uh, we'll just go through the first door.
Hello, sorry for barging in, but I'm a cop.
Is there anything I can steal?
I mean, not steal, borrow.
What's this?
Judgment is nigh.
Crude charm.
Okay.
Obtain fire.
Don't worry, a cop would never steal.
we're here to borrow we'll return things eventually that's
what the taxpayers money is for we'll pay you back with your
own taxes
uh oh when the time never mind do miss og i miss og resident
evil now
i wish this was the og resident evil for this was less scary
back in the original The graphics made it silly.
Oh, bro, are you okay?
Sorry to barge in like this.
Bro, you okay, sir?
Those eyes don't look healthy.
What are you doing in your own house?
Huh?
Wait, that's him.
That's Marty.
That's Mario.
Oh!
Sir!
What are you doing in your own house?
Oh, fuck.
Self-defense.
They can arrest me.
It's self-defense.
It's not my fault.
It's not my fault, guys.
He attacked me in his own house.
So I...
house and it's self-defense even though it's his house just
remember okay can I keep this oh is that cat what the fuck
okay we have a key here oh we can't go this way anymore wait
did he lock the door just let me move move the fucking wood.
Oh, wait, no, this is the door.
Oh, why did this get scarier?
Hello.
Oh, no.
This is a cult.
Ooh.
Sensitivity is way too low.
Let me move up the sense a little bit higher.
Where's the sense?
when aiming okay boop boop boop boop okay let me remind this
was better the original they knew what I liked alright hello
oh rats there's the guy that he killed hello hello this is
not a home invasion I have my rights
micro drive they give us super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
Breaking news.
V-Tuber tomato dokeyberry breaks into house and kills...
No!
Self-defense!
I legally entered his home.
God,
Leon, I don't think he's okay.
I don't know.
That sounded...
He sounded very scared.
Oh, no.
Escape from the Hunter's Lodge.
Okay.
Oh, I can shoot now.
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, okay.
If I have my gun now, I'll be ready for anything.
Hello?
I'm legally allowed to shoot you if you scare me.
How do you headshot if he has no headshot?
What?
How do you headshot?
Evie's head is already off!
Oh no.
How do I...
How do I knife?
Okay.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, okay.
Space bar.
Space bar is knife when they get too close.
When they get too close.
Space bar is knife.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Okay, there you go.
I just need to get my reflexes going on here.
Okay.
Alright.
All right, there's a guy right there.
Maybe he's going to walk back.
Sir, are you going to walk back?
Sir?
Can you walk back so I have a longer...
So I don't have to turn around?
Oh, no.
Fuck, okay.
Sir, please.
Please walk back.
Do I go up?
Yes, I go up.
I don't know.
Maybe there's stuff up here.
I know this is not considered getting out, but maybe there's
stuff here.
What the fuck?
What's this?
Also, how's the volume so far?
Yeah, escape by going up.
Okay, so it makes sense.
This is Condor 1.
Hunnigan here.
What's your sit-rep?
The president's daughter, Baby Eagle.
It's likely she's in this village.
Our intel was correct then.
Well done.
Need a location on a nearby lake.
She may have been taken there.
Copy that.
I'll see what I can find.
Where is the president's daughter?
Please!
Dad wants to apologize for saying it's a phase!
Oh no.
How does this game get harder now?
Oh, that is way too many people!
So far.
Oh, thank God.
I don't have to shoot them.
Okay, I'm out of the house.
have no legal rights to kill me because i'm not doing a home
invasion anymore i have my rights
i'm not in this house anymore so now they can't kill me
because i'm not breaking any rules
i'm not trespass exactly i'm not trespassing anymore all
right i'm so scared i'm so i'm so scared of getting jump
scared okay hello is anybody here does anyone have spare
ammo oh asking you shall receive nice i knew it i knew
somebody kept ammo somewhere you win this time ninja thank
you in the super chat thank you thank you oh my god they
painted yellow for stupid people like me!
We guys didn't know.
Early on in game testers, people wouldn't do anything with
the barrels until you painted it yellow.
And the people realized, Wow.
Yellow means I can break it.
When I can customize my case?
Oh, I only have one case.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
My knife is like so fucked up though can we use to craft
ammo okay craft i don't have enough okay dark blade thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you freedom america
woo baby some super chat sent by real american real okay
hello wait did i just go backwards i did okay thank you for
the akasupa thank you thank you save 10 bucks each time my
dumbass co-worker worker said something stupid out of
pocket.
Decide part of it should go to the best tomato round.
Thanks for everything.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasu.
I really appreciate it.
Well, I hear some angry Spanish to my right.
Should I go left?
No, dog!
That's a waste of good food.
I don't think I want to go to the right right now.
I'm scared.
Oh, more ammo.
Nice.
More ammo for me to whiff.
okay approach nice thank god is not on e oh oh oh hello
hello anybody i will shoot wait wait wait wait wait yes yes
i did say i would shoot oh give me a sec i said i would
shoot i said something fence there we go wait what wait a
minute he's not dying he is not dying what is this okay that
is a waste of ammo okay so when they are human when they are
human i shoot the head and then when they become whatever
the fuck that was i shoot the knees okay that's good That's
good.
Ice skating style.
You understand that reference?
I don't even know if I can allow to say that.
No, I'm not thinking of the 20 gifted ships.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
No!
Okay, I was like right in front of it for so long, too.
a bear trap?
Ah!
Okay.
I hate this.
All right.
I need a heal.
Okay.
Flash grenades.
All right.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, you can set your weapon to a shortcut.
Good thing we don't have anything else right now.
Uh, her gunfight, it cannot be used by itself.
Well!
Do I heal?
What's my HP?
How fucked am I?
Okay, guys.
What is my HP right now?
I can't tell.
Oh, there it is.
I'm half HP.
It's okay, Leon.
If you're half HP, you can survive.
American healthcare is still very expensive.
We gotta give you medicine when you're just about to die.
All right.
Yeah.
Knock, knock.
Don't worry.
What the fuck is that?
A head?
Oh, that is a head.
Don't worry, the spray bottles can heal a broken leg.
Oh, remember when I, like, was so fucking stupid and killed
everybody in this town?
I wasn't supposed to.
to kill everybody.
Alright.
And wasted all that ammo?
We can do that again.
It would.
It wouldn't hurt to do that again, right?
Hello.
Okay, there is the police officer.
Oh shit.
That sucks, bro.
That fucking sucks.
Wait, can I put him out of his misery?
Don't worry.
I'll put you...
Oh, he's dead.
Sorry, I was a bit too late.
Um...
Sorry.
I couldn't...
Sorry, I washed a little bit too long.
I could have shot you first before all of that.
Alright.
There was an attempt.
Yes.
I don't know.
Maybe I should just kill them all.
You know what, guys?
I think I can kill all of them.
No, I have 10 bullets.
Never mind.
I just realized how much ammo I have.
Um, shit.
Okay.
Can I just run back?
Alright, here we go.
Alright, okay.
Sneak around first.
Guys, do you think they will see me if I just walk like
this?
Okay.
Nah.
Oh wait, no they won't.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, that requires Ashley.
Wait, there's grass here.
We'll get my grass real fast.
This.
Oh.
They won't know.
Wait.
There she is.
Hello there, granny.
I'm here to take you to a better home.
You'll be okay.
Don't worry.
You're just going to go to a farm down state.
She's okay.
It was a tranquilizer.
It was a tranquilizer, guys.
What do I do here?
Where the fuck are people here?
Tranquilizer.
Where the fuck do I go from here?
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to figure this out.
Oh, I can combine.
Craft.
Mix herb.
What does this do?
Restore three times as much health.
Oh, okay.
Now where do I go?
Okay.
Follow the path what path that is that a path?
Okay
There's no way he sees me There's no fucking No, you don't
see me What the fuck okay Oh, I fucked up guys I fucked up
Oh Is that a door?
Oh Rock door!
Guys, that was the rock door!
Oh, shit!
Don't wait!
Oh, don't worry!
Rock door!
It's okay.
Apparently I don't have a stamina meter.
It's okay!
We've learned!
okay there you go wrong door wrong door wrong door i'll just
keep running backwards we've learned how to do this i ran to
the dead end nothing has changed nothing has changed for me
oh god oh god It's okay!
Nothing has changed!
My knife is stronger!
Leon, please!
You're so strong, Leon!
That's great!
Go!
Nothing has changed for me!
Okay, alright, let's go get some heals real fast.
It's just like old times!
Okay.
Oh, please don't tell me he's over here.
Oh my god, hey guys!
Oh fuck, bye guys!
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine!
I'm reloading, it's fine!
It's just like old times!
Never forget!
Woo!
But I couldn't make it at you in time!
Okay, okay.
Woo!
What the fuck are you doing here?
Don't worry.
I can run.
I cannot run around, but I can run down here.
Don't worry, kick!
Oh, please leave me alone!
Oh!
Kick!
Woo!
Shit!
Okay.
Guys, okay, it's fine.
Three bullets in a dream.
It's okay.
I have a friend.
All right, nothing else changed.
Nothing else changed.
If you close your eyes.
Woo, thank you.
Just keep running.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, just keep running!
They'll kill their friends!
Oh my god, Granny please!
Woo!
Seraphity!
I ran out of ammo!
Unlike last time, I don't remember where all the ammo is!
Oh, my knife is broken too!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I know there's a- I'll get it when everybody's dead!
Guys!
I'll grab the shotgun when people are dead.
But at the moment, we don't have that.
Shit, it's okay, she missed.
It's just run.
Guys, I don't have the mental fortitude to grab the shotgun
right now.
I don't know where it is.
It's totally fine.
There's so many houses.
Which is the right house?
Oh, thank God.
Luck.
I did it now I can grow through the houses
Oh I survived
Oh I did it Carl thank you for the super chat Thank you
thank you here lies Doki her night broke She ran out of
bullets Here we go.
First try.
Say the line, Leon.
Say the line.
Leon!
Where's everyone going?
Bingo.
He said the line!
Resident Evil.
four holy fuck we did it all right let's go find out how to
get the axe or the shotgun please stop talking to me I need
to get the fucking shotgun
windmill copy that and be careful first out go me and ninja
thank you the super chat thank you thank you okay let's go
grab some ammo all right oh nice we can craft stuff here he
set the thing guys he did it i open this okay oh oh okay
that i mean a good thing i didn't find these guys or i would
have wasted it all on this mission guys just remember i
could have wasted that if i found all these items I wasted
my inferior regular handgun bullets instead of my instead of
my shotgun ammo.
I'm big-braining it, guys.
This is all big-brain.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the shotgun?
I'm so confused.
I'm already lost.
What is that?
What is this?
Oh, Gap in the wall.
Yeah, it's all part of the plan.
Guys, it's all part of the plan.
I would have wasted it.
I would have wasted my shotgun ammo on something inferior.
Okay.
That nice handgun ammo.
We needed that.
Whoop.
Where the fuck could the...
Is it that?
Over there?
Can I vault over this?
Nice.
I can't.
Oh, shit.
There's stuff here.
From all the people that I killed.
Money.
Me is taking the super chat.
Thank you.
He set the thing.
Chainsaw guy would have... Yeah, but no, but...
I was never gonna kill him.
There was no way.
Is it... Okay.
I don't know if you guys think I will actually remember the
leg.
I like how you guys think I remember this layout.
It's been two years
There's a key here
Okay, all right nice.
Okay, you just gave me five bullets.
I mean five hundred dollars That's all right Where the fuck
could...
Yeah, I can't believe it!
He's not praying!
What the fuck is he doing?
How... Where am I?
How dare he?
Oh my god.
The church's not gonna like this.
Found a man not praying.
Ooh, nice first aid spray.
I missed a yellow bear.
there guys it just wasn't yellow enough i guess
wait where i killed him oh he's oh there it is nice money
all right off i go okay thank god ashley is still not here i
don't i don't think how it would have gotten very well I,
like, I'm just getting PTSD of the Ashley missions.
Oh, there's the shotgun.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
And then I'm going to steal.
I'm going to borrow this real quick.
And then...
Oh, what's this?
Nice shotgun ammo.
Okay.
Can I jump out?
Oh, now you don't want to jump out the window.
Oh, okay.
Oh, is there items here?
There might be anything here?
Any items?
Any loot?
Am I done looting?
I can't tell.
I'm already lost.
Not that would.
Why can't he pick and choose what window?
Does his life or death?
It shouldn't matter.
I got here?
Yeah, I did.
I loot everything?
Can't tell I'm so fucking lost.
I can't tell everything looks the same to me Okay, this is
just an empty area Anything here?
Oh, herb I love my grass Shoot the chicken Does the chicken
give me loot?
Chicken, do you give me loot?
Guys, that was a perfectly good bullet I can't believe it
Guys, this is exactly Thank fucking God I'm not playing on
hard mode.
That would have been my last bullet.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's a locked drawer.
Knowing you guys, that would 100% been my last bullet.
If I was on hardcore mode.
I missed the ammo right here.
Alright, there is...
is a... Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Thank fucking God.
Alright, let's see.
The ladder here.
Wait, what's the ladder for?
Oh my god, that's a ladder!
I didn't even realize that was a ladder.
I thought it was just interior.
Erb.
I'll need this.
I don't know.
have a knife i broke it what do you mean you have a knife
dead poor i broke my knife
go back to the chicken and pull the bullet out because i
don't know if you guys know how guns work but uh i'm pretty
sure that's not how guns work what's in here oh ruby that's
right you're I'm the heirloom is mine now.
There's also a house here.
Nice.
More ammo.
Toki, you don't understand.
If you throw it really, really hard, maybe it'll pierce that
guy's skin.
Open.
I swear.
I need to be careful of bear traps now.
Knowing me, I might step into all of it.
Wait, what?
That house?
I mean, there it is.
Here?
That far?
I already missed OG.
I already missed OG Resonant before.
It was definitely a lot less scarier.
It was campier, which meant I wasn't as scared.
When can I customize my case?
If I quaffed, Cool greens.
It's twice as much.
Then...
Might as well make more shotgun ammo.
Yeah, shotgun shells.
Time to play Tetris.
Nope, nope, don't discard it.
I honestly would not be surprised if I accidentally discard
this.
Okay, let me save again.
Friend, thank you for the magenta.
Super!
Thank you!
got this I believe you for the bloodline Doki for the
bloodline think about the bloodline Leon chicken is that
fresh water oh there's a cow shoot ask questions later
oh my ass two headshots okay there you go there you go we're
fine oh hello lady I remember you.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Lady, lady, lady, lady.
Give me a sec.
Okay, there we go.
I'm charging up my gun.
There we go.
Oh, fuck.
Um, nice.
Cow's just chilling?
No, that cow's dead.
Wait, there.
Nice.
Okay.
Wait, do you have eggs?
What the fuck?
What am I gonna do with an egg?
Can be used.
Oh my god!
You wanted me to kill the chickens?
They give you unlimited heals!
They have eggs!
Brown chicken egg?
Is that better?
Oh my god, the brown chicken eggs are better!
Ow.
Did that chicken fucking hit me?
Okay, maybe I'll kill this chicken.
Oh, it's a male.
I can kill this chicken.
It's a rooster.
He wasn't going to be providing any eggs.
It's okay, guys.
It was a male rooster.
Let's see.
I need to make sure.
Okay, far, I'm here.
Freddie, thank you for that 50.
Get the chance.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Wait, the pig... Okay, to be fair, pigs are carnivores,
though.
They, like, uh...
They eat anything.
Like, that's what they say.
People say, like, if you just, like, throw a body at a pig,
like, it's, like, one of the best ways to, like, hide the
bodies, because they'll just eat the body.
That's why, like, pigs can even eat their own kind.
If they, like, if the pigs got cut or something, the pigs
will smell the blood and will be like, ooh!
yeah pigs eat everything will I ever use the grenades
see well to be fair any animal eats their own babies it's
not just pigs that's a dead boy they give me one of five
give this shit thank you thank you it's not like a pig thing
every every animal eats their own babies because it's like
survival the fittest so if they think a baby is not worth
like taking care of they'll just just eat it because they're
like it's not worth it okay I need a key for that because
they're like I'm not gonna take care of this baby that's too
many babies so then they'll just eat it to like what the
fuck I heard somebody who said that hello hello where are
you are you trying to open a door
Is that her?
I hear you.
She's inside.
Hello?
Oh, ma'am.
There you are.
Where did you come from?
Can you get a little bit closer?
Thank you.
That's a lot easier.
Get a little bit closer?
There we go.
Can you turn around?
All right, here you go.
Where did she come from?
Wait, where did she come from?
There's no entrances here.
Hello?
Where did you come from?
All right, time to open the door.
Boop.
No good.
Oh.
How the fuck did she get there?
Medallion?
Where's the medallion?
I already looked through everything.
Where did she come from?
Where did she go?
The chickens watch the chickens?
What do you mean?
They seem like...
They seem like good chickens.
Blue?
Oh, you mean this thing?
This thing?
Do I shoot this?
I forgot if I shoot this.
Oh, I do!
Okay.
I remember now.
Oh, there's another one!
Right here!
What a waste of perfectly good bullets, though.
There you go, two.
Wait, what happens if I find all five?
This is new.
I don't know, or maybe it's not.
I never was an achievement hunter.
Maybe it wasn't new.
I just don't ever realize.
It's worth it.
If only I have a knife.
I know!
If only the chainsaw guy didn't fucking fuck me up.
Oh, there's one.
Where's the last two?
Are all of them are in this village?
Wait, they're on the map too?
They are?
Liar!
What the fuck do you mean?
The blue paper?
Wait, is the blue paper considered?
You can take on tasks by collecting the blue request notes.
View the request you've taken.
The love of God with some.
Please get rid of blue medallions.
Those religious lunatics left hanging around.
Rewards.
Spinell 3.
Wait, what the fuck is...
What the fuck is a Spinell?
Oh, there it is!
Oh, I should have taken the blue paper first.
Wait, how do I get that?
I can't even get there.
Huh?
Okay, that other one I can get to easily.
That one's here.
Wow, chicken!
Okay, now I know why people said, watch out for the
chickens.
Some dally in here?
Where?
I don't see any blues.
Where the fuck is that blue?
What?
Oh, gamers don't look up.
Oh, my God.
Fucking it.
Of course.
Always.
It's always up.
How do I get there, though?
I think I need a key.
Blues clues.
Fucking wacky-ass blues clues shit.
Like, how do I...
I can't open this door.
From the window?
Can't get up.
Can't get up there.
Windmill?
There's a windmill here?
Oh, there is.
Hello?
Oh, that's a bomb.
Okay.
Can I just...
Okay, I'm just gonna walk under it.
Wait, can I disable it?
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Okay, thank God.
I almost thought that was gonna fuck me over.
Hello?
Anybody here?
Grab this yellow herb.
Hello?
Anybody up top?
I feel like there's somebody up top.
There's always somebody up top.
I'm coming up, guys!
I'm gonna announce my...
I'm gonna announce my appearance!
Oh, what's this?
A puzzle?
Gotta fix everything myself.
God, what happened to the repair people here?
My God.
If I was an inspector...
If I was an inspector, I would close all of this down.
There you go.
Bye.
I did it.
Where's my spindle?
A red herb handgun.
Nice.
Can I go through here?
Free loot!
Wait a minute.
Wait, who the fuck is that?
Who the fuck is that?
Who's that?
Who's he?
No!
Off the ladder!
Are you dead?
Okay, I'll just shoot you in the head now.
Oh, it's you!
I'm sorry, I'm trespassing again!
Oh shit, please don't climb up the ladder, please.
Please, I'm reloading.
Okay, thank God.
Here we go.
We're good.
It's fine.
Are you guys dead?
Oh, I don't have a knife.
I'm just going to shoot you in the legs then.
Alright, heal.
I have to shoot you in the legs because I don't have a...
I don't have a knife.
Are you dead?
He's dead.
Oh, thank God for ladders.
Thank God!
Saved by the ladder!
Nice.
We did it.
Oh, they got a kitchen knife!
That would have been so helpful earlier.
Oh, nice Ruby, too.
Alright, we did it.
We got the...
Saved by ladders.
I love it.
You want me because the ladder buffed.
I wish I could have taken that guy's fucking hammer, though.
Hammer seemed pretty fucking neat.
Alright, what the...
Okay, can I not be used?
Can I combine the hands other...
You know what, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna come craft.
I'll mix the red and the yellow.
What does it do?
I'm gonna increase my maximum...
Oh, wait!
That's good!
Should I just eat it now?
Or the throwing axe?
Yeah.
Red, yellow, green.
I might as well just eat it now.
I don't need the heals at the moment.
Yeah, but I don't need the full heal.
I feel like that's a waste.
I might as well just heal this.
Get this.
Wait when you...
Fine.
I'll wait until I...
I'll combine it with the green.
Fine.
Okay.
Tetris.
Nice.
God for the fucking high ground shit, though.
Did I get the thing automatically?
Where's my...
Whatever the fuck that was.
There.
Can I claim it?
I destroyed it all.
Does it automatically go to me?
I'm confused.
Confused, jokie, right now.
Oh, at the merchant!
Okay.
I have to visit him.
Is the merchant the only same person in this village?
Okay.
Why doesn't Leon take the weapons?
Is he stupid?
Thank you, it's a super chat thing.
Thank you.
A knife made for cooking its edge.
All right, well, this is apparently my knife now.
Well, can I fix this?
I guess, like, I have to send it to the merchant to fix it.
What is this?
For selling only.
2,000.
What the fuck?
The ruby is more expensive.
Wait, actually...
Wait, there's...
There's, like, a place I haven't gone here.
Alright.
Yeah, my fucking kitchen knife.
Be scared.
I have a kitchen knife now.
Woo.
Nice money.
Open?
Is that the...
What?
What is this?
Buying treasures.
You can view the treasures.
Some treasures can be sold out of by fitting them.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
I just put...
Can I make this more expensive?
If I put two rubies, do I make this more expensive?
Ooh.
Now ruby number two.
Ruby number two.
Oh, it plus 3,000.
Wait, but like, it's already...
Wait.
But if I sell it, it's already 3,000.
Like, what?
Okay, two gems.
Oh, one times two!
Oh!
I feel like I might as well...
It gives you a bonus.
Well, I can only combine two right now, so I might as well
just combine the double.
Oh!
quick maths.
Oh, barrows.
I want all this money.
Come on.
Yes.
Okay.
Wait, can I kick this too?
Ugh.
No lock can contain these thighs.
Neil, they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm not sure Merchant even is a person considering his
magical.
That's just his twin brother.
Or triplets or like, I don't know, he just comes from a very
big family.
You don't understand.
It's like Nurse Joy's.
The Nurse Joy's and Officer Jenny's.
They're all just like one big giant family.
They're like the merchant family.
Right.
I'm gonna save my game.
I don't trust myself.
Get out of the way, pigs.
I'm gonna save my game.
I'm gonna save my game and lose the bathroom real quick.
Wait, where's this over here?
Where it all started.
I'll be right back, guys.
I saved the game.
Alright, I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
It's okay.
We saved our game.
Nothing bad's gonna happen to us now.
That's how it goes.
Alright, up, I'll go.
There we go.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh my gosh, I almost forgot where I was.
And then Shady, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Irene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank my first super.
Irene.
Oh, no, not here.
Bro, not the chainsaw, man.
Do I have shotgun M?
Okay, three.
Let me...
Let me reload.
real quick.
All right.
Here we go.
I remember this place.
Seeshavu.
What's this?
Can I push this?
Wait, do I push this now or later?
Oh, maybe this isn't.
Is this it?
Is this the place?
Okay.
Oh, you're right.
I have the grenades too.
Don't worry.
I'm very prepared this time.
Wait, what?
What's over here?
Maybe there's something here.
Jesus Christ, Leon.
These fucking thighs.
I'm worried.
I'm always worried straying off the path now.
I feel like anything's gonna get me.
Leon's never skipped all right um do i have to go up here i
mean i could just go this way what if i don't go up to that
house i could just go this way i mean it wouldn't hurt
nothing
can hurt me if i go this way
Ashley is over there.
Maybe it won't matter.
Alright.
Hello?
Oh, it doesn't matter anyway.
I couldn't fucking open the door.
What the fuck, guys?
It doesn't matter.
I couldn't even open the door.
Alright, there.
It's fine.
It was not even loot anyway.
There was a even loot there lie the illusion of choice okay
are there any fucking traps no traps okay thank god okay
oh my god my thighs those thighs save me yet again good job
leon uh the double illusion of choice.
I love the doubled illusion of choice out there.
Let's see.
Nice money.
The power thighs.
Save me yet again.
I knew you had it in you, Leon.
Those thighs will never...
Thick thighs save lives.
Well, still locked.
What the Fuck, where do I go then?
Where do I go?
I go back on the back?
Maybe do I drop down from here?
No?
Was it the right way?
Oh, they didn't block the path?
Oh my god, I thought they blocked it!
I just thought it was blocked!
Okay, let me go back then.
Hell no, fucking rocks fell down.
I didn't know Leon could climb.
I mean, he couldn't fucking climb before.
Oh, it was just logs.
Oh, shit.
Oh, oh, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
That's not cool.
Guys, I can shoot through this, right?
Oh, I can.
Grab the needle.
I love cheese.
Okay, where's the other guy?
Where is the other guy?
Wait, where is the other guy?
Oh, he's over here.
Okay.
I love cheese.
Wait.
I killed them.
There's load over there.
I killed them, though.
Right?
here why is the tree shoot oh sorry gamers don't look
anywhere but straight nice so easy okay can the granny get a
little bit closer granny i need you to get closer so i can
hit the head thank you granny granny can you run a little
bit closer thank you granny granny you're just You're almost
there, Granny.
So I don't have to run too far.
Okay, there you go.
Thank you, Granny.
It seems...
Look, these thighs...
These thighs need to break right now.
These thighs need to break.
I need her to get closer, so I don't have to run too much
for loot.
And I need to make sure I don't fucking step on bear traps,
too.
I feel like Doki's gonna grenade herself And set up, yes,
100% That should not even be a question Jin, thank you for
the super chat Thank you, thank you Look, there has to be
like maintenance On these thighs, you can't like overuse it
Where the fuck is my flashlight How do I ping my flashlight
to be used?
Like It is clearly dark, Leon Turn on your flashlight Okay
Okay.
Oh, hello.
F?
It's not F.
I tried.
I didn't think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello?
Hello, guys.
Oh, there's Granny.
Who are they trying to...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
Wait, where is he?
Oh my gosh, where are they?
I hear the bomb!
Oh, okay.
Okay, he blew himself up.
It's like, I hear it.
Hello?
I know Granny is over here.
Granny?
Oh.
Oh, there it is.
Whoop.
Hello.
What?
That's a hit!
There we go.
Oh no.
That's five.
Oh, melee!
Nice!
Thick thighs!
Save lives.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Thick thighs!
Oh!
No!
Okay, I'm just gonna deal with this gap first.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Give me a sec, gotta reload.
Give me a sec.
Oh, give me a sec.
Oh, my god.
Okay, that's good.
That is good.
Oh, there are more.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Don't hurt me.
I'm in my suitcase.
Do not hurt me.
Oh, God.
Okay, thank you.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Wait.
What?
Where did she throw that?
Where is she?
Time out, time, time out!
Huh?
Ma'am?
Ma'am!
Where are you, ma'am?
Where is she?
Where's the invisible granny?
Ma'am!
I don't like this.
I don't know where the invisible granny is.
Is she up there?
Grandma!
Please!
Come down, I won't hurt you!
I'm just gonna take you to a farm downstate!
I swear!
Granny, please come down!
Your family's worried about you!
This is a tranquilizer gun!
There we go.
Bye.
I hope she's not going to turn.
Is she going to morb?
No, she's fine.
I just need her head to poke up for like one second.
There you go.
Oh, no.
She's fucking turning.
Oh, oh, shit.
Jesus Christ.
Please.
Granny.
It's alright.
We're just going to wait a little bit.
There we go.
Okay, is she going to...
No!
Fuck!
I hate these bear traps so much.
God damn it.
These stupid fucking bear traps.
How do I...
Okay, how do I disable this?
I see you.
I acknowledge your existence.
How do I disable this?
I acknowledge it's...
Oh, knife.
Okay.
okay
what do I do why oh oh thank god I thought I like stepped on
it oh thank fucking god I honestly thought I just stepped on
it oh thank god I didn't step on it guys there's hope wait
how do i how do i get in oh i hear something here oh oh
there's a crystal what is that what is that sound i don't
like this where the fuck is that sound they collect the book
oh it's above me i see it!
How do I get it?
Do I just shoot it?
Oh, I do.
Alright.
I do.
Alright, that will be the only collectible I get in this
entire run.
Alright.
That should be...
I swear to god, if there's another fucking bear trap.
I swear to fucking god.
Okay.
Just making sure I didn't miss anything.
Alright, we didn't go this way then.
Did we miss anything?
No, we did.
Alright.
Reloading.
Wait, there's more?
Oh, there is more.
Sir, please.
Get away.
Oh, no.
I have to...
Oh, no, he's...
Okay, he's not...
He didn't turn.
Oh, thank God.
I thought I had to, like, fucking knife him with my kitchen
knife.
I didn't necessarily...
Oh, it's...
Hey, guys.
Remember this?
Wait, before I shoot the lake, is there a safe point
anywhere?
Is there a safe point?
Guys!
Please tell me I don't have to restart my entire...
again!
Oh, this is the wrong, oh thank God, this is the wrong part
of the lake.
Okay, we're just gonna admire the scenery.
Alright, that's, thank God, okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
It's the wrong part of the lakes.
I hear people inside.
Can I go over here?
No, I can't.
People inside, though.
I'm ready.
I reloaded my gun.
I'm ready to shoot whoever is in there.
Self-defense.
I swear to God if there's a bear trap.
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh.
Which way do I go?
Hello?
Oh.
Something like that.
Somebody's inside there.
That's very angie.
Hello?
Yeah, I know, but like, I want to know, like, if I could go
inside.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Oh, my God.
Please, Leon.
Leon,
please.
Leon, please.
Please, Lee.
I don't understand.
I knifed him!
I don't understand the mechanism.
I fucking hate hunting.
Alright, nice.
At least I got ammo.
It's fine.
I got ammo.
This was all I wanted.
I don't need a crouch, okay?
That's good to know.
Oh.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Again.
Door with insignia.
I don't have that.
How do I get to there?
All those years of training.
The police academy didn't train me for this.
The house?
Did I try to go back into the house?
Where did I get in the house?
Oh, there's a door.
This is the place.
Sorry.
That one thing I didn't see.
Let me.
I have a warrant, but please don't check it.
Hello?
I don't like this.
I feel like...
I feel like there's definitely somebody up top.
God damn it, everything needs keys.
What?
Why do you need keys for?
I saw you.
you guys are we're a safe town so safe
uh okay oh i wonder if i can can i shoot these can i shoot
these guys
sure i brought okay look they should not be scared about
people stealing stuff there's like less things to worry
about right now like that should be the least of their
worries like people stealing i mean i'm not stealing i'm a
government worker.
That doesn't count.
I'm a government worker.
Let's see.
Oh, I don't know.
I feel like there might be somebody over here.
Aim by with knife equipped, then use knife to stab.
Okay, you guys see it as if it's so easy.
What's that noise?
Woo!
They're not innocent.
Oh, fuck.
Whoops.
Sorry.
Wait, what?
Why am I...
What?
Why am I instantly aiming?
What the fuck?
No, my two bullets!
What?
Why did I shot?
I just right clicked.
What happened?
I right clicked, guys.
swear wait what what's going on i can't how do i my third
bullet how do i how do i get rid of it
okay okay okay i fixed it okay that was weird that was hello
can i get i'm gonna stab him with my butter knife oh okay
never mind whoa shit okay don't worry thick thighs save
lives nice how the fuck oh yeah my you know what no my
thighs are like really my thighs my legs are just that
strong i have to say how the fuck was he not able to cut it
with his fucking axe but i can like Stomp it?
I'm like, what?
He had an axe!
That's just Leon's power.
Oh, now I have my flashlight.
The skill diff right there.
I was like so confused.
Wait, oh, is that Ashley?
Yeah, that's Ashley.
I can't shoot it.
I had to make sure.
You're not, Ashley.
Oh, you're the other guy.
You're the guy people wish Leon was.
You want to talk.
How observant, Seor.
Now, say, you got to smoke?
And all those things will kill you.
Oh, well, maybe just untie me then, huh?
Oh, no, it's a chainsaw map.
Wait, who are you?
Oh!
Oh god!
Not the legs!
Only...
Torso up!
Please!
Oh shit!
Pro lives!
Chapter end.
Nice.
Okay, what's my results?
Oh god.
I performed a stealth kill.
Oh, I did all of that.
Appearance at everything changes.
Ooh, I did everything.
Okay.
Shift.
Save game.
Alright.
Nice.
It's okay.
We saved someone better than Ashley.
You will receive our most sacred body.
What the fuck are you?
Okay, this is fucked up for me to say he looked like
Queen Elizabeth the second's husband.
May he rest in peace?
Stop it.
Leon.
I'm doing Sarah.
Guess you, me.
I like how everyone was like Adam Sandler not expecting me.
Stop.
He was like, Adam Sandler?
And then I'm like, him.
Bet you've been in spots like this before.
No, no, that's good.
The jacket's gone.
Now that he can see my gains.
One more guess.
Maybe.
Wait, his name is actually Adam Sandler?
Whoa, that's awfully close, man.
We're bros, right?
chatter about moving a seniorita moving here where who knows
but later saw some men dragging someone to the old church
hanging with you bro it's just whoa oh
it's okay bro oh my god bro are we like best friends now
Oh my god, bro, do you feel this?
Do you feel this chemistry right now, bro?
Oh, shit!
That's how fast male friendships go.
Bro.
I know, like, male best, like...
Male friends is basically, like, you don't know any details
about their personal lives, but they're there for you, bro.
When guys are best friends, And then they're like, you know,
what's his family life now right now?
And you're like, I don't know, bro, but we're going to be
playing some fucking Call of Duty later on on Friday.
True, bro.
He's like, what's his job?
Bro, I don't fucking know, but his IGN is like, uh, Major
Hawk.
I heard it from this guy I met.
Said his name is Luis Serra.
Bro, so true.
There's something fishy about him.
I need you to run a background check.
We'll call Condor 1.
I'll see what I can find.
No, my stuff!
I hoarded so many items!
Right.
I'm probably due for confession anyway.
Condor 1.
Out.
Don't know who their names are.
They're just my bro.
Wait, I should take this chain and, like...
And then use the chainman as a fucking whip at the...
Wait, where's my bro?
Bro, he already left me, bro?
Bro!
up bro at least i have my herbs oh no bro he already left me
what the fuck i thought we're homies i didn't know the real
name of one of my friends until two years later because
everyone called him by his nickname bro thank you for the
zoom chat thank you thank you alan bro left me No, not the
stealth, bro.
Oh, nice, my kitchen knife.
You can perform a wide-swinging slash.
You can also do a quick slash with space.
I'll be like, ha, ha.
Wait, ha, wait.
Ha, ha.
Okay, there you go.
Thanks, bro.
I hate this.
Why did they make this stuff?
Was this, was this in the original game?
I don't remember this.
Gone.
attend get the ships they can thank you this sucks i must
have like deleted this portion from my mind bro i definitely
don't remember this
okay if you sneak behind and oh i already done that before
hello
I'm trying to find my bro.
Nice.
Another kitchen night.
Have you seen him?
What's this?
That's my stuff!
Where's my stuff?
Where's my jacket?
What the fuck's...
I should be wearing shorts.
Oh, look.
Turn around.
Oh, he did not turn around.
guys.
Guys, I don't think he turned around.
Nice.
I did it.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it.
Yay!
We have another... Oh, wait.
Okay.
Are you having...
You're British now!
Okay.
London simulator Jesus Christ If you have a knife Wow Well I
never needed to know that Apparently If you have a knife you
can parry and attack with space When a prompt appears in the
bottom right corner You can successfully parry If you press
it before the prompt Appears time it right And an enemy will
be Wow that was That would have been good to know earlier
Well I beat him I killed him so it's fine Okay, even if you
press it before the prompt time, right?
And then, okay.
Time this right.
Okay.
How do I do this?
Oh, I did it.
Oh, my God.
I'm learning.
Oh, my fucking God.
Can't open this.
No!
My gear!
Please!
Kick it with your fucking legs!
You use this...
Oh, wait, can I kill this rat?
Okay.
Walk on it.
Nice and more kitchen dives.
What I've always wanted.
How the fuck do I get my shit?
Give me my stuff!
Give it to me!
Let me in!
Okay, I can't get it.
Did I get caught?
Don't worry, I have this window.
I don't think I got caught.
There's no way.
He's just talking to his friend.
I have this window.
See, I told you I didn't get caught.
Okay, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
There's no way he's gonna turn around Turn around
Not yet not yet not yet not yet not yet Okay, nice Alright,
thank you for the money Just gonna mug him real quick All
right.
Okay, nothing here.
Oh, I can open this.
Hello.
My gun!
I'll never use a knife ever again.
Oh, God.
I gotta go fast.
Please, Leon!
Your legs!
Leon!
okay nice okay i got all my stuff i'll never have to use my
knife ever again i'll be taking these back nice okay and
then unlock here and i don't have a key where the fuck are
the keys where are the keys yeah let's craft this real way
actually put this wait what what's this is this my storage
what is this what is this what is this is that storage i
don't know what this is this is trash okay okay oh that's
the ground okay why the fuck does it look like a case i how
was i supposed to know that and shows by god all right yeah
it's more space okay we're gonna put this here petris
whoa friend
hello mr merchant stranger Who's that?
That's your new best friend.
Your new bro!
What's this?
Get rid of the rats that take.
We don't know they're carrying any berat.
Oh, hey!
Wait, I can go back and get rid of the rats.
I sure got rid of the rats earlier.
Guys, I could have got rid of them earlier.
I know there's one of you right here.
Come on, get over here.
Get over here.
Come on.
Come on, I'm gonna shank you.
Come on, let me shank you.
Fuck, I don't think I need to shoot it.
He's too fast.
Oh my god, oh my god, look at him, go!
Please, walk into my crosshair.
Bro!
Bro, he's so fast!
Okay, he's gonna tire himself out.
There we go.
I should have just done that.
I should have just laid for him to tire.
himself out.
There you are.
Okay, let me walk away from you.
Where are you?
Alright, Ty, you're gonna stand still.
Come on.
Tie yourself out.
There we go.
Where's the last rat?
Oh, there you are.
Alright.
Alright, come on.
You're gonna waste up all your energy.
That sugar's gonna die down.
There you go.
Nice.
Yes.
Easy.
yeah new york experience all right done i got the rats took
care of a request did you yeah i did why the look on your
face why are you selling trading oh he didn't say the thing
merchant request once you've collected completed a task
received from blue request note you can claim the reward by
talking to the merchant yeah you've proven yourself reliable
i did it yeah i swear they got the bullets worth more that's
not he didn't say the thing he didn't say that thing wait
but he didn't say the thing do i even oh i need to fix my
knife yeah four thousand dollars bro Who gives a fuck about
my knife?
I'm gonna sell shit right now.
He has that no large can be sold.
Bro!
I'm just...
I'll just use my kitchen knife.
Why should I fucking...
Bro, why should I fix it when I have perfectly good kitchen
knives?
It'll be worse.
Perfect.
Okay, let me sell this first.
Okay, I'm gonna sell these two.
And I don't need this, right?
Yeah, that is not usable anymore.
It's not the same.
Welcome to capitalism.
I'm gonna sell some of my fucking kitchen knives.
All right.
Can I sell this key now?
I don't remember.
this cheese would be most as cheese with you airplane ninja
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i won't
need a parry if i have my gun all right so i think i got
everything i need a deal well struck okay two fine god that
was a lot of money good luck to you stranger
You want me to...
You want me to increase the durability?
Okay, this is time.
This is time for you to shine.
This is backseat time.
Durability?
Okay, durability.
What else?
What else do we need, guys?
What else should we...
There's durability?
Oh, I thought that was my fucking gun.
I was like, there's no fucking way there's durability on
gun.
Case upgrade?
Okay.
Where is case upgrade?
Bye?
Okay, case upgrade.
I have enough money for that.
Alright, case upgrade.
Alright, what else?
What else do I need to upgrade, guys?
Wait, I can trade the spinels?
What do I trade it for?
Oh, yeah!
Oh!
Do I...
Get the Punisher?
How have we procured these curiosities?
Do I need that?
I don't need that.
I have you guys.
The rifle?
Do you get the scope free with the rifle?
Is the rifle that good?
This one?
I don't have space for it.
Is it that good?
Is it actually that good?
No, I meant the rifle.
Is this the rifle?
Yeah.
Yes?
Okay, fine.
I'll do it.
Okay, let me like... I need to fix up my suitcase first.
Give me a sec.
I need to fix up my suitcase.
Let me...
up okay storage okay we can okay let's put away how do i put
away this ship uh shit okay get in
no fuck okay i didn't realize dragging it no my green herbs
okay i learned that dragging it turns it into dragging it
turns it into like yeah i i learned that today i wonder if
this fits does this fit does this fit i don't how big is
that fucking how big is it customized case how do i take you
to the storage oh auto sort no what does the auto sort do
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna abide now.
I should have enough.
Boop.
You're gonna just make sure.
You make just make your space.
Okay.
This is awkward.
I can.
I figured this out.
Oh, I can.
Oh, I know.
I know.
Okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
This is easy.
I'll just put this up here.
Wait, what?
I can't drag this.
Oh, okay.
god damn i'm so stupid i can't read god how do i function as
a person sometimes look at all me all my kitchen knives
though there you go yay do i have ammo for this gun wait a
minute i just yes
I did it.
Yeah, we do not have ammo.
Oh, thank you.
I got a scope.
Yes.
You're a man of good taste.
Thank you.
That's how you keep your customers.
All right, I have no money now.
Now I'm actually broke.
Can I, like, buy ammo?
You have ammo for me?
I don't know if he has ammo.
No, he does not.
Okay, what's both using resources and no, I don't guys, he
doesn't have ammo guys.
He does not have ammo.
I don't have, do I have money for the, oh wait, this one?
Alright.
You've got a soft spot for treasure, eh?
Okay.
Our map is updated now.
Oh, I see.
Lock, drawer, treasure, treasure.
Okay, I see.
Nice.
Oh, free ammo!
Tino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All sorts of feats the purpose of a Tetris inventory system.
Think of the principles.
Good thing I couldn't figure it out because I didn't realize
it was hold alt.
That's your streamer.
I didn't figure out you were supposed to hold alt key.
So I had to do it the real way.
You know, you traded this to Nels here, Steve, reward for
valuable goods.
Oh, that's cool.
There we go.
Alright, what's this?
Exagon-shaped slot.
Treasure.
Which way do I go?
Okay.
Oh my god, it's all... The objective is all over there!
The eagle.
When will I ever need to use...
I guess I'll use my rifle for bosses and the little guys.
The little guys.
will be used for uh that's my streamer i'll use the pistol
for the little guys there's no way i'm using wait a minute
there's no way i'm using the rifle oh we have to attach the
scope where the oh i do bam there you go attached
get closer get closer closer.
That's right.
There you go.
You're closer.
I don't want to waste my legs.
Oh, shit.
I accidentally... Get closer.
There you go.
Nice.
Come on.
You're almost there.
Boop.
Nice.
I don't have to waste my knife on you.
That's good.
Thank you, Granny.
Are you learning bear traps?
No bear traps.
Ooh.
I don't like this.
This doesn't seem very stable.
Oh.
Oh, what's that?
Who's that?
Okay, I'm gonna climb.
Hey, guys.
I don't know if this is Sable or not.
Oh, look at all these grannies.
Look at all these grannies over there.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
That's okay.
They don't know where I am.
Right?
Okay, that's fucked up that I missed.
No, he doesn't know.
See?
He's so confused.
Oh, goodbye.
Look at them.
Goodbye, Granny.
Don't worry.
There's, like, inflatable balloons down there.
It's, like, up.
Can you walk down the stairs for me?
Oh, my God.
Not that slow, though.
It's okay.
There you go.
Easy.
Wait, are they not gonna walk up to me?
Why would I use rifles?
Rifles are so expensive ammo!
If I can shoot them with a handgun like this, like, I don't
need the rifle.
Okay, not like that, though.
Oh, now I miss!
I hit every single shot earlier, but now that I get a little
cocky, I start missing.
I see, I see, oh, fuck you.
Okay, where is, I need a fucking, let me equip, register
this as a shortcut real fast.
All right, I've had enough.
I had enough.
All right, dude, fuck this guy, though.
There we go.
all right okay i don't need to use the rifle on her though
watch all right here we go there see i can do this i'm not
wasting my fucking ammo guys i can look see for some reason
that guy didn't work but first oh my god that was like the
only person I missed shots on.
Everybody else I've hit.
Guys, pistol ammo isn't wasting ammo.
They're so fucking...
It's so easy to find pistol ammo.
Why is the wind so big now?
It's because I killed everybody?
Are they mad?
Why is the wind mad at me?
What did I do?
Alright.
Why is there boss music?
Guys, what did I do?
I don't want to drop down.
The wind god is angry at you.
There's nobody up top, though.
Oh, okay, the wind stopped.
I don't want to go down.
I'm scared.
What the fuck are you?
Bro, he just ran at me.
Okay, there.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Nice.
I don't like this.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, shit.
I didn't realize there were more.
Oh, what the fuck?
There are so many!
What?
Okay, no wonder the wind gods were mad.
Whoa!
Okay, okay.
It's okay.
That's fine.
That's a good casualty.
Oh, God.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
Oh, did you see that though?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no!
No, don't grab me!
Please, let me go!
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Okay, it's fine.
We're fine.
Woo!
That's fine.
We're fine.
It's fine.
There we go.
See, not a waste.
Not a waste.
I got my ammo back.
ammo back guys it's not a waste please let me in whoa please
don't tell me this is never ending
guys i swear to god is this i swear does this end does this
end does this end
i hear a lot
This is never-ending!
I wasted!
What do you mean?
Let me in.
Oh, hey, but look.
I didn't realize this is never-ending!
I wasted so much!
Please.
Oh, God.
Where am I?
Oh, good.
God damn it.
Okay, I'm okay.
She was too fast!
My knife!
That's okay.
Everything is fine!
Fuck off.
Oh god, oh god, thighs, thighs, dude, don't fucking fuck me
up now.
It's fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine,
we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine,
we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Where's the ladder?
Wait, there's no ladder here?
Guys, I didn't realize there was no ladder.
You think this is a choice with me running in circles?
I'm literally panicking!
All right, that's fine.
We're okay.
Oh god.
There's so many!
Oh!
Shake!
Shake, shake, shake, shake!
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're
fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're
fine, we're okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay,
Where am I?
Drop down, Leon!
Drop down!
Please!
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, up top we go, up top we go, up top we go.
And then we just shoot them off the ladder.
Who has a...
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
Is there anybody on the ladder?
There we go.
Just guard the ladder!
Guard the ladder!
The ladder strat!
That's fine.
They can't give me about the ladder!
It's the ladder strat!
They can't get up!
There's one ladder!
I only have four but oh no they're getting up they're
getting up guys I fucked up
okay it's fine
I it's not fine guys it's all it's it's fine are we good now
are we are we okay Are we...
Are we...
Are we okay?
Guys!
It's okay, we don't need the pistol.
It's okay.
It's fine.
This is exactly why we don't play hardcore.
This is exactly why.
...
There we go.
This is one of the big reasons.
This is exactly why Doki cannot do hardcore.
Okay, here we go.
We're going to grab the amount of resources that I took.
Boom, boom, boom.
All right, we're good.
Everything is fine now.
We survived.
So it wasn't never ending.
So that was a lie.
That was a fucking lie.
Whoever said this was never ending.
There was an end.
There was.
Thank fucking God there was an end.
All right.
Was there any loot here?
Any loot?
I went through so much.
God, I went through so much, guys.
Please, we're on the loot.
Boom.
Okay.
Just gonna make sure I...
Make sure all these doors can be opened.
Oop.
Hello?
Oh, hey.
There's a little chest here.
Oh, there's a key.
Where does this key do?
Yeah, I can go up, though.
Open the locker.
All right.
jump scared in three two one oh okay that's cool all right
thank god
missing hexagon oh i got the hexagon emblem the item that
was supposed to get okay where the is the key supposed to go
more lockers that missed out more Is there more lockers down
there?
Oh, there is.
Jump scare in 3, 2, 1.
See?
Look at that, guys.
It's like I didn't waste all my handgun ammo.
See?
All right, let's see.
Oh, there's more.
See?
There's more.
I didn't get punished.
look at that not punished got more handgun ammo look at that
right wait what I heard somebody over there what hey do I
see that where what the fuck where did you come from
where did you come from lady all your fucking family's dead
where'd you come from no the fire my ambience
bro she's late to the party her husband died like 10 minutes
ago bro she's so fashionably late What the fuck?
Where did she come from?
Oh, shit.
Jeez.
Thanks for lighting that, though.
Nice.
We got the ruby.
Did I use a key?
Wait, did I just use the key for that?
I did, right?
That was the key, right, guys?
You know?
She was also sleeping in.
The key is for the small drawers?
Where is the key, though?
Where do I use it?
I already opened everything here.
Yeah, got everything.
I need to loot her body, though.
You climb up that ladder.
A small locked drawer?
Where the fuck is that?
There were so many.
Oh my gosh, dang god.
I got the ammo I wasted on those two ladies.
I passed by money?
No.
No, we can't let that happen.
Back at the...
Oh no, I have to fucking go all the way back there?
Alright.
I did it.
I killed everybody in the village.
It's alright, guys.
I did a good thing today.
Hello.
save game
all right i think i can afford to oh i cannot i'm so broke
never mind where i can okay guys i feel like i can upgrade
my gun
guys not gonna lie but like i don't know what do you think
the investment on the power of my pistol.
Yeah?
Is it worth it?
No, I actually need actual advice.
Is it actually worth it?
Yeah?
Okay.
It's worth it?
Okay, pal.
Alright.
I mean, I've been fucking using that.
I've been fucking shooting people in the head.
There is a better one.
There is a better one?
I mean.
There's a better free gun?
Not worth it long run?
Okay.
okay do i just not do it wait until we get a better free gun
i can sell it better anything you like stranger okay but
when do i get the better pistol what chapter okay guys i
need to know what chapter do i get the better free gun i
worth it now okay people are saying it's worth it now in
like two Okay, I'm fucking investing in this.
I'm investing this.
You guys said in one to three, like chapter three or four.
And I'm like, yeah, no, we're fucking investing this.
You guys don't even know.
That's way later.
Exactly.
Okay, we're gonna fucking open up the chest, wherever that
is.
What is this?
Here?
The lock.
Oh, there it is.
The locked drawer.
Yeah, there it is.
Okay.
Nice.
Boom!
What's this?
It's a mask!
Can I sell this?
This is also...
There must be another treasure over there too.
Okay.
It's okay I can make my money back.
There's a treasure right here.
Right?
Like here?
Oh!
I didn't open this!
Nice!
There's a sapphire.
We might be able to find another of those, like, pots things
that we can use to double the value.
Nice.
We need to find the pot, though, so we can double the value
of this.
Alright.
So.
Oh, I can add it on the mask!
Nice.
Alright.
Key items.
I'll just do it now.
Gems.
Okay.
blue yellow if I find red blue yellow I can get one point
okay I'm gonna see what gems I can get before I add it yeah
I'm gonna see what gems I can get all right save thank you
welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome all right put
that eagle in oh I have to rotate it I don't know
oh Oh!
Oh, I see.
Oh!
Okay.
There you go.
I didn't realize I could turn it.
Okay, I see.
I can see it now.
I see.
I definitely see.
There you go.
Open sesame.
Hello?
Where's Ashley?
Oh.
myself now my kitchen knife this is it this is what my
kitchen knife is for stop walking stop walking stop walking
stop walking there oh what the fuck was he oh shit okay okay
that's awkward where did this man come from
Oopsie No, no, ma'am.
I don't know what you're talking about.
That was a little awkward, though.
That was whoops.
Hey, don't turn.
Don't turn.
Oh, no.
Fuck.
I just saw it.
God damn it.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's just a little flesh wound.
Just a little.
God, air.
Thank you for the 15 gifted chests.
Thank you.
Thank you!
I appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
It was worth it.
Can't believe crouch was E.
It's okay.
Man, I think with all these areas, I was definitely supposed
to stealth.
Whoops.
Does this work?
Oh, nice.
Sapphire.
Wait.
Do I have two sapphires?
Okay.
What was the combo?
Oh, if I had two gemstones of the same color.
Ah.
Ah, okay.
Never mind.
If I have three.
Wait, three of the same color, though.
I need to find another blue gem.
I need to find another blue sapphire.
Oh, resource.
Oh, the fuck crouches with some sick fuck that thinks
actually is important.
Alright.
Let me make sure.
Oh, I missed out on the bullets on my bullets ammo where's
the ammo where is it ammo oh there it is nice uh okay i need
a let me like craft some ammo real quick uh oh okay we need
rifle ammo that's for sure and then do we have enough for
shotgun no okay let's just this here and then just tetris
this just a little bit it's fine let me just eat an egg a
small amount you know what one egg wouldn't hurt all right
we're good we're gonna find more eggs anyway what if i shoot
a crow can i get like a bonus oh my god crows get loot oh my
god a hundred dollars 150 dollars that's like an akka right
there jim thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
that's right i know you have money inside you now
now i know no bird is safe anymore no crow is safe the money
crow the legends were true the money crow wait where's your
money what the fuck how come you don't have money i got
scanned one bullet is very expensive the was my money crow
oh god
okay nice okay not a waste herb the influence is not what it
once was destroy the wind up dog do not give those
aristocrats.
Oh, no.
Bourgeoisie versus the poterette.
Wait.
Is that what they're called?
It's been a while since university.
Okay.
Alright.
It's been a while.
Oh, gunpowder.
We need that.
Wait, I can make the shotgun.
Right?
Is it 12?
Oh, no, it's 12.
I cannot make it.
They got everything?
No, there's so much loot here.
What else is there?
Treasure.
Where's the treasure?
Do I shoot this?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No, they don't.
What do you mean?
There's nobody behind me.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait, is that chainsaw?
Is that chainsaw?
Is that...
Oh, fuck.
It's okay.
This is what it's for.
That's why.
Can I kill him?
Can he be...
Okay, guys.
Before I waste more ammo, can he be killed?
Okay.
That's good enough.
Trinzelman, please.
I need a reload.
Trinzelman!
Ah!
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Ah, yes, we did it.
Oh, we did it.
All right, that's good.
That's good.
Thank God for them stopping.
Let me check my chat.
Okay, we should be able to make this now, right?
all right nice and then here and then here what what what oh
it's circular i'm so fucking stupid yellow not guys the
square shape goes in the
okay sorry i i don't know my shapes as well guys I'm just a
little special I don't know my shapes Where is that?
There's like loot somewhere here See that?
I'm standing where loot is
I'm looking up To this Oh God I'm so smart I looked up guys
Guys I looked up that stinks okay we got it oh close the
hatch what you can do that well two
how is i supposed to know you can close this
it's okay it's still money now you got your circle no it's
ruined
It's okay.
Just...
Just a little mistake.
It's fine.
Alright, let me...
Is this Ashley?
Ashley?
They definitely made this longer.
I swear it did not take this long to fucking find Ashley.
They definitely made this game much longer than the first,
the original.
Wait.
This trap is being used.
Reload the save.
I'm not going to reload the save.
Crow, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Take the loot.
Just don't shoot me.
It's too late.
Now that I know you have money inside.
What if you fucking...
What if you're like...
Holding out on me, huh, Crow?
What if you try to hold out on me?
Facts.
in the super chat thank you thank you I don't like this I go
for outside oh I need a key
where I can like set these back no?
Why are some traps like on and some aren't?
It's weird
okay I've learned
oh yeah that's right you can't get me this time that's
fucking right Figuring it out.
You can't catch me now.
Oh my god, that scared me for some reason.
Hello?
Any bear traps?
Whoop.
Any bears?
Okay, there's two...
There's two treasures inside.
Thank you for the...
Five gift of the ships.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Hello?
Oh!
I'm sorry!
It's a toilet!
Oh, no.
Chainsaw Man 2.0.
Lord Crow says, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Toilet Man, we meet again.
It's like things never changed.
What, you meant crows were holding out on you?
Oh, well, take my money anyway.
Thank you, the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not too shabby.
just like just like before oh what's wrong with why did you
scratch their faces it's messed up how do i rotate the other
way though oh i can't look at the back okay i guess i didn't
want to this is key nice got my key what's this treasure Oh?
Old photos.
Okay.
Oh, Q-N-E?
No, I can just spin it.
No, I meant turn it.
I want to turn the photo to the back.
It's nice to know Toilet Man is still there.
Oh.
Um.
What is this puzzle?
What the fuck is this puzzle?
Is it from this one photo?
is this oh there it is it's left click god this is the worst
though at last flesh of our flesh blood of our blood give
thanks and rejoice okay that was useless anyway all right
where do we do this puzzle oh oh wait let me reread that
sorry my memory is not that I'm only good at remembering
parking spaces.
Like, where we park and stuff.
What is it?
Flesh of our flesh.
Blood of our blood.
Give thanks and rejoice.
Wait, what?
Flesh of our flesh.
Blood of our...
Oh, sorry.
I just, like, kicked the thing, like, always.
Wait, that doesn't make sense.
Flesh of our flesh.
Blood of our blood.
This is not a clue.
That's not the clue.
And they keep looking.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, it's a hand grenade.
I can barely see it.
Can we find the clue?
Oh.
Oh, doesn't matter.
Gunpowder.
Alright, craft shotgun ammo.
I need that for sure.
Oh.
Oh, that doesn't matter.
How are we?
Who does puzzle?
The other photos?
That photo doesn't make sense.
Wait, isn't that the...
Oh, I thought that was the...
Oh, it's upstairs?
Okay.
Make sure there's nothing here.
Nice.
Chicken egg.
What... Is that in the oven?
Why is there a chicken egg in the oven?
Ma'am!
I'm not gonna judge you.
But ma'am!
Alright, hello?
I think my bro is up here.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, herbs.
I can combine this.
Nice.
Okay, save.
Alright, here we go.
In great veneration of their master, the people offer up
their most prized possessions.
The old farmer, his finest crop, the slight swine head, his
stoutest pig, The beggarly grandam her own beloved babe the
mask.
Oh, that's it.
Wait, what was it?
Sorry, crop pig baby.
Okay, we got this.
Crop pig baby.
Crop pig.
Wait, why am I saying that loud?
You guys can tell me.
Crop.
Where's the pig baby?
Nice.
Ooh, what's this?
crystal marble that's it I should be able to steal all these
other things inside the drawer and sell it to the sell it to
the fucking
whoo whoo whoa stop stop stop stop oh shit my kitchen knife
okay I thought I didn't realize he was the mutated guy I
didn't realize it's okay I have so many kitchen knives all
right no that's not the poop man that can't be there's no
way did the poop man mutate him is that actually you oh my
god it's the poop man is that gold it is him i knew i should
have double shanked
god damn it my one mistake never i didn't double tap okay
save This is gonna be paranoid saving this entire time.
Alright, hello.
Oh, it was...
I can't sell this.
Wait, what?
Oh.
I hate this, though.
I hate this so much.
There we go.
Should be it.
Wait, what?
This should be it.
No, it's not.
Okay.
I hate this.
Wait.
This should be it.
Ray?
No?
I hate this.
That's so sad.
Okay.
Okay, this should be it.
Oh, this should be it!
There we go.
Nice.
I'm smarter than the child.
October 10th.
The weather has been strange of late.
The wheat withers, and the cows grow thin.
December 8th, there are signs of famine.
It is true.
They lack the means to work the fields.
But Lord Sadler's orders are absolute.
January 30th, 30 people have starved to death.
Five cows will be slaughtered.
March 11th, the patriarchs gathered to cast lots of six more
chosen for Lord Sadler.
April 8th More today Four more today Eleven more today Two
outsiders got lost and wandered into the village We took
them to the altar for the ritual No need to cast lots today
Oh Alright So it's like the lottery system Yay Oh there he
is Aww Oh I thought he would like Fucking show up okay oh
the insignia key what's that no i forgot to take the bullets
no bring me back bring me back no no my handgun
no oh bro oh wait aida that's not my bro not my bro I can't
believe it where's my bro who's my best friend all right
chapter results oh we got a lot yay money nice 81% of
accuracy you guys are that i think that's pretty good i'm
pretty sure you guys are like not 100 not my streamer not my
gamer not my gamer rooster condor one i've got that intel
you requested on louis sarah it seems he used to be a
researcher for umbrella umbrella i should have left him in
that bag to rot i'm sending you the details take a look but
i saw a mod where you can like change leon into wester you
can just play as wester please when will i see ashley that's
all i want what's this whoop ashley
okay what's this oh i guess i can look at him again all
right class wait did i grab all these i did right oh yeah i
did okay i'm gonna go up then all right oh i don't have
ashley okay never mind that doesn't matter okay okay
apparently i can't jump leon apparently you can't fucking
jump and grab onto this ladder but that's okay
that's okay i don't i don't care that much i guess I'm
scared now They're like just gonna be someone Leon cat chump
At the end of chapter four When did Ashton take this long to
get?
I swear I'm pretty sure that he made this game longer They
definitely made this game longer I wanted to see my fucking
Hot topic Ashley
Okay Okay Hello?
Hello?
I don't know, I don't trust this.
I don't trust this.
Hello?
Oh my god, I don't trust this at all.
But I hear a dog.
Dog?
No, dog!
Don't worry, dog!
I help you!
Don't worry It's okay I'll spray it Wait Take care of
yourself buddy You're supposed to give me XP We're gold
Alright Well goodbye dog Okay Insignia is like behind me
Alright The fuck was my gold The crows gave me gold Gold
All right, here I go.
Use.
We saved Dad.
All right, where's my bro?
I take my bro or Ashley.
Oh, I don't like this.
Ooh, yeah, turn on your flashlight.
I don't like how he doesn't turn on his flashlight instantly
when it's dark.
I don't like that.
It's dark.
Okay, is it safe?
No?
Just a random shed here?
What do I do with this random shed?
Alright.
Too dark.
I don't like this.
This is way too dark.
Turn on your flash.
Leon, please!
Leon!
I'm gonna fucking bring out my shotgun at this rate.
Okay.
Like...
I don't like this.
Oh, wait.
There he is.
Wait, there's a villager.
Hello.
Hello?
Oh, that's another village.
This is another village I'm gonna slaughter.
Because I don't know what stealth is.
I guess it is.
Hello, villagers!
Come here to kill all of you!
Oh!
Because I don't know how to stealth!
Hello?
Where are the villagers?
Oh, another village.
Another slaughter.
Hello?
Oh, wait.
This is the first village.
I've been here.
Alright, let's see.
I should be able to go.
I get this drawer now.
And there's a treasure here, too.
Wait, I can be able to...
Wait, where's the objectives?
What the fuck do I get over here?
Like, what?
How the fuck do I...
Jesus, Chris, what is this map?
Alright, let's grab...
I don't like this.
Hello?
Hello, guys.
Alright.
Let's open this door for...
Oh, come on.
Who set this trap back?
Huh?
Hello?
I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
I'm so nervous.
Yeah, why is this village so fucking quiet?
Hmm.
Hello?
quiet village doesn't make me happy where do i go i go all
the way back
because they're playing bingo true they're still playing
bingo right now
what's going on what's going on what the fuck there's bad
wolves there's bad There's bad wolves, there's bad wolves,
there's bad wolves!
No!
Oh god, oh god, there's bad wolves, there's bad wolves!
That's fucking right...
No!
Shit!
Don't!
Shit, okay, okay, I'm gonna heal.
Please reload, please!
Oh god, oh god.
Oh my god, my fucking shotgun.
Holy shit.
I can't believe there were bad wolves.
If evil, why bad evil?
What happened to the karma system?
I saved wolf.
I get reward.
The karma system was a lie.
This is why you never do good things.
Wait, what?
Is that for Woos?
This is exactly why you don't do any good thing ever again.
It was never worth it.
Why save Woos when Woos still evil?
How the fuck do I use this map?
Guys, I'm fucking stupid.
It's the ladder?
Oh, fucking...
All right.
Oh, hey, I mean, I should take this herb, though.
Might as well.
I guess ladder?
Where's this?
Oh!
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, I don't like this at all.
Hello?
I'm just gonna shoot some boxes.
Hello, is that rat?
That's a rat.
Okay, that was just a rat.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna...
Fucking destroy your barrels.
Alright, nothing to be scared of.
Oh, what is this?
What is this?
Oh...
Oh.
Honestly, I thought they would just come out of the trash.
Low-key thought they were gonna...
Oh, hey there.
Thies!
Save me now!
Ah!
There we go!
Sick thighs!
Let's go!
Wait, wait.
Is that a chainsaw?
No, that was not a chainsaw.
Okay.
I'm...
happy for my thighs.
Nice.
Alright.
We're good.
Oh, we're good.
We're okay.
Guys saves lives.
Yeah, that's right.
This life, too.
I'm gonna make sure.
Did I get everything here?
Let's see.
How do I go to the door with the insignia?
Yeah, there's nothing here.
I think there's nothing here for me to loot.
We can go to the church now.
Boop!
Hello?
What's that?
What the fuck was that?
Mad snake!
Oh, I got a snake.
Nice.
Can I sell this?
Oh my god, my favorite fucking kitchen knife.
that's definitely what i need
oh is this their church what the fuck kind of church is this
okay i don't need to look at this man's face for the fifth
time what kind of church is this that's a giant skull that's
yeah where the what the fuck how did they Get that.
Sleep well and flourish, dear child.
As your body grows, your mother shall sew new small clothes.
At seven quenches of wheat and half a bowl a day, you have
outgrown your pen.
Flourish, dear child, for the sake of your brothers and
sister who cannot.
That's a John-ass fucking scholar.
Whose head is that?
Whose fucking head is that?
oh my god that boy grew that's a big boy I think I'm running
out of inventory space that has a lot of heads okay the
smell in this place must not be great not gonna lie this is
not the best smelling place
merchant nice nice That's good.
That means I'm safe.
What's this?
Sick of constantly running out of ammo?
Well, I got a treat for you.
The bolt throw is something else, mate.
It bolts can be retrieved and reused.
So you can keep shooting forever.
Also, don't forget to buy the bolt recipe to turn your extra
knives into, well, bolts.
Nothing to worry about ammo again.
And that's not all.
You can fix the bolts with detachable mines.
Skip ad.
merchant if you are telling me to buy your bolts that means
that means it's a scam you have too much in stock you can't
fool me i used to i've told the story before but for those
who are new here uh back when i was in like middle school i
used to live in asia i used to sell like overpriced like
anime shit to like people in America on eBay I used to run
an eBay store you can't fool me merchant you can't so in in
middle school I opened up an eBay and I just sold like um oh
my god One of them was like Italia trading cards and like
because like when I bought the trading cards like they were
like, you know They're like super cheap where I was in Asia,
but then like people in America They were trying to get like
collectible cards from Italia like the more the most the
collectible ones so that I sold Individual cards on eBay The
rare cards I had So it was you I I I did that and I also
sold like anime posters from like magazines because like you
can get like the you know like those anime magazines where
you can get like posters and stuff uh it's okay okay it
wasn't a scam when people people back then could not get it
it's not a scam i was your only way to get these items and
so like you know in like magazines those anime magazines
that has like posters of like anime characters and it's like
exclusively only in these magazines so i bought those
magazines and then i would sell the posters within the
magazines because like people really wanted them so you
can't fool me merchant you can't fool me that's something i
would do i'd be like hey this the world very exclusive cap
fool me look i was in middle school okay i gotta hustle okay
look it was it was a tough guys being in middle school
trying to make money it's supply and demand bro exactly
supply and demand Is there anything I can sell?
For selling.
Oh, wait.
Is there any of them that are like that need gems?
No.
Okay.
We're going to sell.
We need to sell the velvet blue, the vintage, the pearl.
Do we sell vipers left to sell for the vipers?
Oh.
Do I sell this now or later?
Yeah, but if I find a yellow sap if I find a yellow one then
we have three but wouldn't wait actually I'm gonna sell
these three first.
Should I sell the viper now?
I should or when I find I could just wait until I find like
Sell now.
Okay, I'll sell now Okay, all right.
I'll sell it now.
I'll just sell these for now and then I'll do the others
Okay.
Apparently I have...
Okay, remove gemstones.
Okay, and they...
Wait, is the three the same color better?
Oh, it is!
Boop.
Okay, there you go.
I can just sell this.
Sell.
Buy my fucking mask.
Nice.
Ooh, that is a lot.
Alright, guys.
Should I buy anything or should I?
Guys, should I buy anything?
or uh or do i upgrade guys what do i do stop chat telling
you wrong things upgrade okay i'll upgrade what do i upgrade
uh what should i upgrade uh tune up the knife guys i'm
mostly using my kitchen knife though the nitro billy said Go
get the...
Why would I need the TMP?
I don't think I need the TMP.
Guys.
I don't need it.
I have the pistol.
Guys, I don't need it.
Okay, I'll do the durability of my knife.
I'll do that.
And then...
Rifle upgrade.
Should I upgrade my rifle?
Pan?
What do I upgrade?
Um, do I get power?
Or...
Do I get power?
Power?
Okay, I'll do power.
Power.
Okay, I have enough money.
I can also power...
Uh, naturally, I can... What do I do?
I have 20k.
Do I put all in on power?
All in?
Better snipers ahead?
Okay, I'll...
Power and reload speed.
Power and capacity.
Okay, capacity or reload speed?
Reload?
Okay, I don't know, guys.
I have enough for either all in.
Oh, better sniper in castle.
It's a long way.
Absolutely.
Okay, max power.
I'll max power this then.
I'll max power this just for bosses.
ultimate power.
Oh, wait, what's this?
A girlfriend?
Oh, this is the snakes.
Delicious vipers.
Is there a snake charm or willing to...
Okay, this is the snake thing.
Alright.
Let's go.
I think 100% made this fucking long.
I would have met my bro by now.
I would have saw my bro.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Oh, I can sell this again.
Hello.
I need you to buy my velvet blue.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm gonna save again, just so, just in case.
I had to get the treasure!
What do you mean, wrong way?
There was treasure over there.
Oh, the lighting is so weird sometimes.
I'm learning.
This game has teaching me to look up hello hello who's there
whoa I made it I made it bro are you here bro bro oh okay
wait I might be able to stealth this you won't turn around
right
yeah yeah yeah there you go nice we let him dig his own
grave nice thank you for the money honestly i'm just killing
them for the money at this point like that's more important
it's all about the money whoa shit whoa bro okay the thighs
Nice.
Wait, did I alert people?
Hey, guys.
Did you guys hear that?
No, right?
Oh, no.
Okay, that's good.
Nobody heard that.
Thank God.
What the fuck?
That's a random coffin over there.
Resources.
Nice.
That's okay.
His life didn't matter.
Thank fucking God.
It's alright.
Nobody know.
We're fine.
People didn't like this guy anyway.
Nobody liked him.
Alright, will he have money?
Let's find out.
I knew it!
I knew you were holding out on me, you crows!
I'm fucking...
I'm the iron.
I'm the lone shark.
I'm here to collect my pay.
I fucking knew those crows were holding out.
I knew it.
I'm...
They can't get away from me!
I knew they were holding out.
It's our money now.
Mushy Mushy.
The church is sealed up.
And baby eagle?
Negative.
Nothing yet.
But they sure do have this place locked up tight.
I see.
I can think of one reason they'd want to do so.
How would they lock it?
I'm perfectly safe.
I'm a police officer.
Okay, we need like an emblem.
Climb over the...
I don't think we're climbing over anything on that.
I don't think so, guys.
Okay, there's some treasures here.
Oh, there's more treasures.
Wait, can I go through here?
No, it's locked.
Alright, we're gonna go through here.
Wham!
Okay.
hello hello
oh what's this a pressed fro he outside has come what the
key i'll be held in the cave on the side the monster will
okay the key okay i cross the lake okay there you go
what's this is that ashley ashley what are you doing keep
her locked in a church until the appointed time this is not
the outfit we picked for you oh no not this words look that
was a little difficult to read okay can i open this oh i can
okay where do we go i'm gonna go outside first something
over here oh i like this this is spooky i don't like that
spooky scary is giving me okay what's this the traitorous
twins should not be allowed to rest in peace for joining
that evil cult wait someone destroy the emblems engraved
upon their tombstones oh okay i just need to like destroy
their graves that's something I can do.
I like it in headdress.
What the fuck is that?
Oh my god, there is no space.
Oh, I need craft.
Shotgun shells.
Wait, is that small?
Okay, I can, yeah, always make shotgun shells.
Wait, craft.
Fuck, I should be...
I forgot.
I forgot I had these guys too.
Can I combine them?
I cannot.
Okay.
Okay, this is I have a lot of grenades.
Woo!
Great desecration.
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Let's hope there's nobody back there!
Alright.
Oh, I can stash!
Oh, never mind.
I thought I can, like...
Where are the twins?
What?
What if I just destroy every grave?
Does it matter?
It shouldn't matter.
What if...
It shouldn't.
It shouldn't matter, right?
You can.
Yeah, it doesn't matter if I just destroy everybody's
graves.
Like, who cares?
They're dead already.
Go for it.
Who's gonna fucking stop?
me their parents who's already dead because i'm i'm pretty
sure i've already killed everybody here or eventually will
there you go we got one there we did it yeah you know what
just for good luck boom just for good luck there you go we
did it yay thank you for the super chat thank you thank
Crave Robert Doki.
We did it.
Yeah, who's gonna stop me?
Nobody!
I'm ready to kill everybody in this village!
I'm too powerful.
I don't know if I'm should be going up or down.
Oh, up for sure for the extra loot, I guess.
Flash grenades.
What have...
Space still?
I do.
This is like...
This is gonna...
be an issue for sure this is definitely going to be an issue
later on down the line hey guys thank you for the 10 gift of
ships thank you thank you no i don't need an auto sort
that's for i'm a gamer oh hey wait no i don't have the key
for that um now i can go downstairs okay how do i put this
in my storage or is that how i've moved this to my storage
that this is like is this a storage or like can i put stuff
in here or do i have to use it oh only weapons oh oh oh wait
i can put sprays right i'll put sprays Rowan?
Rowan, let me put my sprays.
Where do I put that?
Shift.
Go in.
Oh, certain items only?
Oh, click it.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I don't need my sprays.
Okay, that's good.
I have way too many.
Thank you.
This is why I need backseaters.
Okay, there you go.
I have way too fucking many sprays.
Mill, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're already dead.
There's no brain going in there.
They're already brain dead.
And also, they're in graves now.
They're either, like, consumed by the parasite.
Or, or they're, like, in the graves.
So it doesn't matter.
Can I open this door aside?
Okay.
oh yeah they're already dead or they're dead dead exactly
somebody wait what i already opened it that way okay yeah
they're already food for worms there's like oh that's like
the unlock oh my god it's all the way there the church key
is there the sub of what the fuck okay there you go jesus
jesus Christ.
How... Guys, okay, give me a sec.
How... I didn't look up how long this game is.
I'm actually curious.
Okay.
How long is Resident Evil 4 remake?
Okay, 15... Okay, original.
Four original.
15 and a half.
Wait, the original was longer?
Wait, really?
Is this the original was longer.
What?
Bro, they padded this chapter.
There's no way!
Oh, hey.
Can you come downstairs?
Come down.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I guess I'm fucking won't be.
Did he come down yet?
I can't tell.
There you go.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Yay!
Oh, shit.
There was more.
Alright, it's fine.
That's fine.
Maybe I should not have wasted...
Guys, maybe I should not have wasted the ammo, the barrel
there.
I didn't know there were, like, four more people coming in.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
That's fine.
Nice.
Wait, there's more of you?
Get over here.
It's okay.
I have a lot of pistol bullets.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No!
My loot!
What?
What did you do?
you say Leon?
Why do you went puh?
Right.
Oh!
Nice.
Oh shit!
Shake!
Okay.
We're okay.
Oh my god.
That's alright.
I figured it out.
It's okay.
You really heard that stabbing.
Wait, where the fuck was he throwing at?
Maybe I should just start shanking.
Maybe I should have upgraded the power.
What the fuck?
I clearly...
Wait, what the fuck?
I clearly chose the wrong thing to upgrade.
Do I need to shank you?
Wait, there's more of you?
Okay, that's fine.
it's fine i can shank you later all right and she's burning
that's good more loot for me that's good go keep the shanker
this is what i've been waiting for finally a game for me
okay i got back all the ammo too that's good too i got all
my ammo back and the money yeah thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you actually the original needed two game
cube cds because it was so heavy the store in one cd the
game is stored in the cds jesus christ no i'm pretty sure
like i'm surprised that the original is longer than the
remake
i'm so surprised i felt like i like I fucking got to Ashley
already in the original.
Woo!
Shit!
This is worth it.
All right.
Nice.
Wait, that's it?
I'll kill two.
Oh shit!
Shake!
We're good!
Okay, nice.
We're good.
Holy shit, we're already coming from.
Where the fuck are these people coming from?
Did I get everything?
No, there's a treasure somewhere.
Wait, I missed out on...
Oh, oh, right here.
I see it.
How do I get it, though?
What the fuck do I get downstairs?
Uh...
Alright.
What do I...
What the hell do I get downstairs?
Huh?
Oh, this is...
later okay later all right if i get there later i've been
thinking for the super chat thank you thank you why doesn't
leon call stars for help is he stupid thank you for this
look this is his promotion okay if he if he can't protect
the president's daughter then what's the point he might as
well fucking get fired he might as well go home guys this is
like This is like his like job to get promoted.
Do you not want him to get promotion?
Where am I?
Like I'm just like where am I all the time.
It's about pride.
Exactly.
If he comes back without the president's daughter, they're
just gonna laugh at him.
You're gonna make fun of him.
Okay, let's go up.
He wants to show stars that he's not just a pretty boy.
That he's more than just that.
What is this?
Oh, no, not this guy.
Oh, my gosh, it's a giant.
It's a giant.
That he's more than just the thighs.
Is there anyone where you can destroy these blue medallions?
The air is polluted by their presence, and I can't bear it.
Okay, query to the fish farm.
Okay.
all of them one jesus what the okay there's like three here
one here all right peta thank you for the five give the
ships thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you this
is what it takes to be promoted i'd rather be homeless okay
look they don't really have a lot that's right that's right
you ain't fucking oh shit not the wolves are more than just
them where the other wolves
okay where's the good wolf oh my god this wolf is so fast i
swear to god okay where's the good wolf i did my fucking
good deed nice what money
can't believe it this game has taught me that good deeds
nothing.
It means fucking nothing.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, actually, Bacon, that is so fucking true.
Wait, you're right.
He doesn't love his daughter enough.
You're right.
Bacon, if the president really wanted his daughter back, I'm
sure he would have sent that more than one guy.
Oh, no, that's where the troll is.
Wait a minute.
That's the troll, man.
I don't want to pay no toll.
Oh, get up there.
That's right.
He wanted his daughter to never come back.
Oh my god.
This man.
This man knows what's up.
You're right.
He would have said two guys.
It was just a...
He knew Leon didn't have it in him.
Where is this?
Do I have to look up again?
I do.
I fucking knew it.
I always knew I had to look up.
Okay, there's a medallion here somewhere.
I'm looking.
Where the fuck is this medallion?
Wait, where is this medallion?
Wait.
What's up, Tom?
Is it up there?
Always look up.
there up all the way there is very high okay i don't have to
care thank god go back to the yard it's outside how is it oh
there it is there it is there you go dark thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you hey dokey currently
recovering from oh god from any like type of t thing this
fucking sucks uh pro tip Don't have bad gums.
Wait, can I open this?
No.
The surgery sucks.
Great stream so far.
Holy shit.
That fucking sucks, bro.
Anything related to, like, teeth seed surgery stuff is
fucking sucks in general.
Oh, now I can clap.
Nice.
I need, like, one more snake.
Get over here.
Snake.
I mean, I'll take money.
Merchant?
There's a thing.
Is this where the merchant is?
Merchant?
That's your flame!
Is it not?
What are you selling?
Nice.
What's this?
There are enough weapons here to get a party going.
Alright, I'm gonna grab this.
Instead of letting your unused guns collect dust, why not
sell them to spend the extra cash to upgrade a weapon you do
use?
Okay.
Oh, I get almost all my money back.
Oh my god, you're not gonna scam people?
You're better than regular merchants.
Alright, let me sell this.
A headdress with red...
Oh, this is where we put stones.
I don't think I have enough stones yet for this.
I need three.
I need like one more ruby.
Uh, I'm gonna sell you first.
I'm gonna sell you two.
And then I need to grab more guns.
Okay.
Wait, can I?
I cannot buy.
Oh, technically I can trade for it.
I feel like I'm gonna wait until I find another ruby.
Uh.
More guns?
None of these guns are worth it, though.
I don't think so.
none of these guns are worth it i'm gonna wait what upgrade
the power of my knife for shanky god damn it chris they got
pleased to hurry the bloodline is fading chris thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you don't okay i will i'll
save my money for now where the fuck is the oh there's
typewriter yeah yes Take the elevator?
Wait, what's the elevator?
Oh my god, there's so many things around me.
What's this?
Hexagon, please.
What was that for?
Oh, the church!
Oh my god, there's so many places.
Where do I go first?
Guys, there's too many choices.
What is the elevator?
Mini-game?
This?
That's a mini-game?
thing?
Is this the mercenaries?
Wait, I just gotcha.
Three or...
What's this?
Destroy the pirates and shoot for the high score.
Are limited.
Each token based on the score for a chance to win.
Oh, that's easy.
Destroy several targets by shooting nearby diamond.
Be careful when shooting a sailor.
Okay.
Some targets cannot be destroyed with one shot.
Shoot as many shots until they break.
the certain conditions are met bonus targets oh okay that
sounds fun all
right we can do this reward uh we'll do the pistol first
okay 100 obtain at least 7 000 at least what do the pirates
and so the sailors look like though okay we didn't do this
okay we know Oh shit!
I didn't see the fucking...
Okay.
Reloading.
Oh god.
Oh god, I hate this.
I'm so anxious.
Does it matter if it's a headshot?
Oh, it matters if there's a skull.
I'm fucking up!
Oh, reloading!
No!
Fucking!
I fucked up, I got, no!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, I understand now, I understand, I
understand, I was, I was, I understand now, okay.
Guys, I figured it out, okay.
Okay, there you go, reload, reloading, reloading.
Okay.
There's like a...
There's like a need.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get over here.
Okay.
We're good.
We're okay.
What's the bonus time?
There's fallout!
Okay.
4 out of 6.
Okay, nice.
Gold token.
Nice.
Okay.
We're good.
We're okay.
A hundred percent.
Okay, we're gonna get that hundred percent.
Okay, we're going to get that 100%.
We can do this.
Oh, God.
That was close.
That was too close.
Oh, God.
No!
I can't believe I fucked up.
I already ruined it.
Okay.
It's already gone.
No!
We were so close!
Okay, this time, this time.
I figured it out.
I'm in the groove.
I'm in the groove now.
Oh, God.
That was close.
I'm in the groove.
Oh, God.
no no no no no no no no no no please
Oh, so rush it don't rush it don't you don't rush it
Don't rush it you don't need a rush
come on No Okay Come on
NOO No
I give up.
I want to try the other one.
Oh my god.
This is so sad.
Someone please.
Play the saddest violin.
The saddest violin.
It truly is.
What is the saddest thing?
Oh, I can collide?
Bro, what?
I didn't know I can collide this.
Oh, fuck, I didn't see it!
I didn't see the fucking skull.
Oh, no, are you serious?
No, are you serious?
Oh, there's 10?
Where the fuck was the others?
I guess like the bonus ones, right?
Okay, wait, wait.
This is what I can do.
I didn't realize there was a collab.
Okay.
We don't need to fucking...
We don't need to zoom in.
We don't need to zoom in, guys.
It's so close.
We already have the scope.
Okay.
Hoop.
Clack.
Okay.
Hoop.
all right all right we figure this out come on okay i gotta
make sure he doesn't have a fucking skull on him no no no
yes no
that was a hit that was a fucking hit i swear that was a hit
that was 100 a hit god damn it That was 100% a hit, man.
This is...
I hate this.
I hate it here.
What?
Oh, it's over here.
I couldn't see him.
I hate it here.
I can't believe it.
My trigger finger.
I'm getting old.
Alright, I'm too lazy to grab the Too lazy to grab the
sniper Unless Boom What?
No!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, sailor Alright, that was not my best Okay, I'm
done I'm done, that was not my best one I'm not my best one
um a gold can exchange all the shooting can i do this what
do i get yay what is this i got 40% off resources oh that's
nice okay what i'll get from this
loo 20% magnum ammo craft bonus frequencies i like that what
is this
That's yellow!
40% ammo resale value.
Wait, what does that mean?
How do I put the charms on?
Okay, but how do I put it on?
Like...
Do I...
How do I put that on?
It's just on me this entire time?
Do I...
Oh, sell...
Sell ammo.
Oh, you sell ammo!
Typewriter!
Oh, okay.
All right, or go to a typewriter.
Hmm.
All right, nice.
Thank you, backseaters.
Customize.
Oh, wait.
Can only put one?
Equip left.
Oh, I can equip everything!
Look at them.
Look at...
I don't remember what they were, but look at them.
What were they?
can i can i see what they are oh there we go it's there
never mind 40 off resources there 40 okay there we go we
figured it out now we're gaming yeah i figured it out i was
like what were they again okay uh let's see 10 000 we don't
need to upgrade anything yet so we can chill.
We didn't chill for now.
Do we go downstairs or through the door?
I think through the door is the troll.
Backseat is saved though.
Oh wait, did I just save?
I don't remember what I saved.
I'm gonna save again.
Repair a knife.
Oh shit.
Did I not repair it?
Tune up.
Let's see.
It's alright.
It has a lot of HP.
Alright.
Do we go downstairs or through it downstairs or through the
door.
I hear very conflicting answers, so I went downstairs.
Shoot the lake.
Okay, guys.
This is it.
I can shoot this.
Are we here?
Oh, not this lake.
God damn it.
Wrong lake.
I am just listening to what you guys are telling me, guys.
Wait, but then what's through the door?
Oh, wait.
Downstairs is just loot.
That's good.
It's just loot.
What the fuck?
What's that sound?
Is there any more loot in there?
Loot?
No more loot.
Guys, one day we'll get to the right lake, guys.
It's just not today.
We just haven't made it to the right lake.
Collectible.
Oh, I didn't even hear that.
Guys, there's so...
Oh, that's the sound I was hearing.
That's like wondering what that sound was.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
How did I miss?
There he is.
That's what it was.
It was just a loot detour.
I got my tangerines.
Let's go.
Is it time to fight?
Okay, fine.
Fine!
I'll repair it.
I have enough money.
Alright, guys.
It's time!
It's troll time!
Can you make sure I reload everything?
I need to make sure everything is reloaded.
Okay, let me see.
Do I have... Oh, I have enough to craft.
Okay, nice.
Okay, craft.
Rifle.
We need rifle anyway.
Okay.
Boop.
here.
Maybe that's your craft another one?
It's time.
It's craft time.
Here we go.
It's time for the troll.
Wait, is it?
Wait, that goes the wrong way?
Oh, it's this way.
Whoops.
Sorry.
It's sorry.
It was this way.
Never mind.
It's not troll time.
It's fish time!
Fish this early?
Hello.
Oh, it is!
When will I meet my bro again?
Wait, who is he throwing?
Wait, is that the...
Wait, who?
Who is he?
Oh, it's a first cop!
Where's our friend?
That's our best friend.
Is that loot?
loot oh my god look at all this loot that I'm definitely not
gonna wait can I shoot the loot here this is a good use of
my rifle ammo
I feel like wait will I be able to shoot the loot
it's not it was not worth it guys the rifle ammo it takes a
while guys guys it was one rifle wait for one Okay.
Oh my god, it's worth it.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Okay, what's that?
Yo, bro, it's worth it, guys.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It's so worth it.
Where's the other one?
This is so worth it.
Where are the others?
Wait.
Oh, but I can get those later.
Bro, wait.
Can I get this later?
They're just waste my money.
I just wait bro one bullet is practically 1k not gonna lie
Is that she no Oh, I get them for whoops whoops.
That's awkward
That's fucking awkward.
I thought it was never gonna be free Whoopsie Well, it's
good to know now The boat fuel is stored with a generator
fuel inside the processing building at the fish farm.
Take only what you need.
Sab.
Well, it's good to know now.
I know now, guys.
What's this?
This is a puzzle?
Oh, I need five more.
Okay.
Is this the lake, guys?
Did we find the lake?
Did we finally make...
Oh, wait.
There's some...
where is it there's one here where the fuck is that blue
medallion
there's a blue medallion here somewhere oh i'm not looking
at it the right direction
question mark is it in here okay i'm not gonna do it but do
it now because i feel like i'm gonna shoot the lake hello
just like old times just like old time what the fuck oh wait
what oh okay just like old time
yeah the dude oh thank you again when did i save did i do
this guys i don't remember when i last saved Wait, what was
my last save?
When?
Okay, I have to do this again.
I have to do this.
Don't remember.
Now I have to do this again.
Oh, my God.
I thought they would auto save me earlier, but I was wrong.
The auto save was not that.
It was not there.
I already shoot him?
I already did.
Oh my god.
Did I repair my knife?
Okay, well no, but if I repaired my knife.
Okay, wait, let's see.
Did I repair it?
I did it.
Oh god, okay.
Let's...
Okay, I customized the case.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Okay, I customized the case.
Customize the case.
That's good.
We're okay.
Case has been customized.
I don't have to worry about that.
Alright.
No, I already have it.
I already have everything.
Alright.
Back here we go.
It's time to look at the fish again.
It's okay.
I saved my rifle ammo.
We can watch this again, our friend.
Yeah, we didn't waste any ammo, guys.
That's the best part.
We always travel.
Nice.
Wait, I can skip?
Oh, I can skip.
No, we won't watch this again.
Yay.
Goodbye, fish.
Goodbye.
Yeah, that was my first death because of the fucking fish.
Where's the castle?
So I was like, look at the castle.
Oh, I can.
Damn.
He's like Lord Farquad.
He's compensating.
Oh, yeah, he's just, he's just as short as him, too!
He is just like Lord Farquad.
I'm not gonna shoot the water.
We've already established the water.
Okay.
Gotta get the money.
The money.
Alright, let's put this guy in.
We need, like, two more.
Uh, hello.
Sparrows.
Got our loot.
Just some herbs.
And another kitchen knife.
Good old kitchen knife.
I'm not gonna...
Guys, I'm not looting this again.
Can't make me loot this again.
Wait, is there an egg in here?
Oh, ammo.
That's even better than an egg.
Ammo.
That's even better.
And I saved my two rifle ammo from earlier.
Alright, we're not gonna...
We're not gonna shoot the lake again.
Uh, oh yeah.
Wait, we need to figure out where the medallion is.
Guys, where is the medallion?
It's like somewhere here.
It's not...
Up above?
Wait, where's the medallion?
Under?
Here?
I don't see it.
Wait, where is it?
Where the fuck is the medallion?
Guys, I don't know.
Let's go back.
I don't...
Guys, I don't know.
I don't feel so good.
Oh, there it is.
Thank God.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I got scared.
I actually got scared.
I was like, guys, I don't know.
I don't really want to go back there, guys.
There's, like, something above.
Like, here?
There's something back there.
Do I go back there?
Or...
I don't know if I should go back here.
I'm worried this is going to advance the...
Okay, this is going to advance stuff.
There's the boat.
Do I click the boat?
Yeah, check the boat.
I'm gonna check the boat.
It's like there was a boat there too.
I swear to God, the fucking fish eats me while I look at the
boat.
I swear to fucking God.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, it's a gas thing.
It's a gas mission.
Oh, thank God, okay.
I was gonna be like, I swear to God, if I check the boat and
the fish comes out, I swear to fucking God.
I'm not gonna- I shot the lake.
I already shot the lake.
I'm not doing that again.
All right.
Hello?
Oh!
No!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
The fish can't be here.
It's too fucking- it's not deep enough.
Oh, wait a minute!
It's him again!
Oh, shit.
Okay, that scared me.
I thought like I got shot at myself.
Okay.
Woo!
Granny, get out of here.
Oh, Granny, please.
Get stuck.
Oh, I can't get there in time.
I can't get there in time.
Oh, oh, wait.
Wait, he's pretty big.
Oh!
Oh, no.
He's gonna turn, but I don't have time.
I don't have time.
I don't have time!
Oh, shit!
Okay, that hit her.
her head.
That was not what I wanted to do, but that's fine.
Jesus Christ, that took so long.
Alright, that's okay.
It's okay.
I still lived.
Not scared the shit out of me, but I still lived.
It hit her head, but it still worked.
Okay?
It still worked.
That's all that mattered.
The fucking ricochet there.
Wait, what?
I heard a snake.
That's like you're right.
You can't get away from me.
I need that money.
You had a grenade.
I think that...
That was such a waste of a grenade.
I...
I did not need it to fucking do that.
Get high ground.
Okay.
We'll take the high ground.
I'm already lost, by the way.
I am...
Did I come from here?
I came from here, right?
No, I did not.
Oh, wait a minute.
Whoa, what's that sound?
Arrows?
Someone shot an arrow?
I don't see anybody.
Am I safe?
I think I'm good, right?
Down I go.
We need our map emote back.
I'll just photoshop a map on top of my dog.
Wait, wait, there is an arrow!
I'm a better sniper than you, though.
There you go.
Headshot.
That's right, I don't need no flames.
Okay, is there anything I'm missing?
There's one more medallion here.
Okay, I'm gonna make sure I kill everybody for before.
Wait, where's that?
Oh, there he is.
Wrong way, sucker.
Loser.
Wrong way.
Man.
That's sucking right.
Please don't turn.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, shit!
That's fine.
Easy.
Oh, oh.
There we go.
You're still alive?
There you go Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, I hear it beep beep
beep beep.
Oh shit head.
Oh shit I heard beeps.
Where?
No, I'm not the one.
Oh shit.
Jotunate Oh, there's so many people.
Oh god.
Oh shit my kitchen knife kitchen knife please please get
your knife okay oh my god it was worth it there you go it
was so worth it wait oh no he's dead all right we're fine
we're fine you saw the Perry's out.
Dude, that Perry's out.
That was some sick Perry.
All right, let's see.
We got to, we can eat our eggs now.
You know, we can, we can eat our, look, see, look at that.
Nothing to worry about.
We ate our eggs.
Guys.
Woo, so calm.
Where is that?
Where the fuck?
Oh, the beeping was.
here.
Okay, I almost ran into that.
Thank God.
Thank God I heard the beeps in time.
Okay, Barrel.
Nice.
Oh, more money!
That's what I like.
Okay, there's a treasure here.
There's like two more medallions.
Where could they be?
Where could the medallions be?
I think I hate finding the medallions the most.
They're so fucking...
Oh my god.
They're so annoying.
Yeah!
A pipe.
God, where do I go?
This way?
Loot!
Love me my loot.
Fish.
Oh.
What?
Can I sell this?
Oh, I can eat it.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Okay, one more.
We need one more medallion.
It's like over here?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, that was close.
That was so fucking close.
There's the last one.
It's like here somewhere.
Who said that?
What?
Where's the medallion?
Where is it?
Like, I'm like on it.
We already have three snakes.
Medallion?
Oh, is it below?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna get that barrel first, then I'll go below.
Below me.
Not here, so it's on the other side.
Alright, we're gonna grab this barrel and then we'll head
over.
We always need... Wait, how do I get that?
It's important.
Can I make this?
I can make this.
Okay.
Alright, Leon.
Sorry, Leon.
Even though Leon's thighs are thick as fuck, they can't be
jumping.
They're not for jumping, clearly.
Those thighs were not meant to be doing any jumping.
Where do I get to the other side?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Did it.
Yay!
Oh, nice.
Another hexagon piece.
Here's something on the other side that dropped.
There's the snake.
You know what?
Extra money.
That's right.
You didn't pay your loans, Crow.
That's fucking right.
Don't think I forgot about you.
Let me in!
I'll make sure nobody else is here.
Yeah, that's right.
Don't think I forgot.
Oh, another egg.
Oh, there's the spool.
This is what I'm talking about.
That's what we needed.
Okay.
There can only be one bird.
There can only be one bird in this game.
That's fucking right.
You didn't pay your rent.
All birds have to pay rent to dokeybird.
I trademarked bird.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I did it.
I trademarked bird.
You all have to pay for the trademark now.
Let's see, craft.
I think I always need shotgun ammo.
Not gonna lie.
I shall craft rifle ammo.
And then I'll craft other stuff later.
Oh, whoa, whoa, I almost got baited.
Holy shit.
I almost got baited by the money.
The bird tax.
That was so close.
Wait, oh, I can stay on high ground.
That's okay.
I can stay on high ground.
That's fucking right.
They can't get me.
Where's the others?
Where are they?
Oh shit, she has a- oh fuck!
What?
Oh fuck, what the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Oh no.
Oh no, okay, I don't have to stab.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Where did she come from?
How did she get there?
That fast!
You kill them all?
Nice.
I'm not a bird bite playing them.
Guess I have to pay for them since I can't.
Because they can't.
Thank you for the super channelings.
Thank you.
Ella?
Wait, what the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Whoops.
Nice.
I need a shank you.
Oh, got back my ammo too.
Don't you love it when you get back your ammo?
And gunpowder.
That's everything.
Money.
Where's that money?
Where's that?
Nice.
Almost missed out on the money.
All these people late for the party.
We had a set schedule, sir.
Up we go.
Do I need a save?
before I fight the fish?
I swear to God, if I die and have to do this part all over
again, I swear to fucking God.
I need to know right now, guys.
Do I need to save before I fight this fucking fish?
Yes?
Okay, I'm going back.
Alright, fish.
Give me a sec.
I'm going back to the merchant.
I might as well.
I have so much stuff to sell anyway.
Alright.
Intermission.
time.
Be right back, fish.
Intermission time.
Nice.
Got this.
Can I trade for anything better now?
Not yet.
Okay.
Let's see.
Antique pipe.
Okay, we can sell that now.
We can sell these two.
And then we can sell our vipers.
Ooh, we have so much money!
Yay!
Nice work.
Uh, what should we do with our money right now?
Your weapons are in good hands.
The laser sight keeps your pistol at full charge all the
time.
Wait, that's so good.
I don't know.
They don't have it.
Never mind.
That's so good.
But they don't have it.
Fine.
I'll repair the knife.
Okay.
Trade.
Oh, it's on the trade?
Oh, wait, do I have enough?
Is it worth it?
Oh, it's the trade.
Is it worth it, guys?
Or should I save?
Do I do it or save money?
Yeah?
Okay, we're getting it.
Alright.
What should we upgrade?
Should we upgrade the shotgun?
Guys?
Should we upgrade the power?
Is it worth it?
between life and dead.
Is that worth it?
Nope.
Okay, that's one guy.
So I'm the one guy I'm not gonna listen to.
And I'll save the rest.
Here we go.
He's like he's not gonna be the only one guy.
I'm coming in too.
Alright,
let me and make sure I reload everything.
Open up.
Alright.
I should have enough.
Okay, let's see.
I'm just gonna eat this egg right now and be full HP.
Like, there's no point.
Okay, and then parts.
Put that on my pistol.
I'm gonna put my fucking kitchen knife in here.
Bump, bada-dump, bada-dump.
Bada-dump.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
All right, here we go.
Fish time, fish time.
Got my fucking rifle.
Oh, wait.
I forgot the puzzle.
Puzzle.
All right.
No, I'm going to keep her for food.
What if I need it?
Wait, can I do a puzzle now?
No?
Oh, I need one more then.
shoot the fish i already shot the fish not shooting the fish
guys we already shot the fish
here i hear you here we go back into the lake i forgot how
this boss fight goes i'm pretty sure as well i'm pretty sure
i'm gonna die here i forgot
i remember i like was so confused when we did this.
Yeah, it's equipped.
I equipped it instantly.
I just remember being so fucking confused doing this boss
fight.
Stab the water.
It's so easy, Doki.
Just fucking shake the water.
Shake the fish.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
Okay, how do I play this?
Shake it!
Wait, what?
Can I just stab the fish?
Stab the fish!
Oh my god!
It is shake the fish!
Shake the fish!
We're doing it!
We're shaking the fish!
I knew it!
I knew we were going to shake the fish.
I fucking knew it.
All right.
What the fuck is he?
Nice.
Wait, let me get my $1,000.
This is important!
Wait, what?
swallow me whole huh oh oh what oh wait that that doesn't
count got my thousand oh what that was a headshot that's
bullshit oh wait whoops that was bullshit that was 100% a
headshot right there that was fucking bullshit so check the
Boss!
Check the fucking boss!
All right, where is he gonna go?
All right, come on.
Come on.
Come on, I know you want to come over.
I'm waiting.
Where'd you go?
What?
Oh!
Oh,
I have plans!
all right we're so fucking dead i got confused i got
confused we're so fucked we're so fucked guys guys i got
confused i got a little bit confused it's okay i wish i know
what his hp is though I really wish I know how fucking low
this fish is.
See?
Guys, GG's.
GG's!
GG's guys.
We had a good run.
We had a good run!
No!
Wait, what?
Oh no.
Guys, it's okay.
We got 20k though.
It was a good run.
Good run!
It was such a good run!
Oh my god, this fucking fight, man.
Wait, we did it!
1HB!
Oh, please.
No way.
first try we did it guys we shank the fish 1hp in our dream
how does she do it how does she always kill the bosses with
1hp oh jesus crazy that's a lot of blood
actually first try yay
accuracy.
That's pretty good.
That's pretty good, guys.
Alright.
Save.
Here we go.
We're in London now, motherfucker.
Leon's body is the most sacred body.
That's why he's going to continue the bloodline.
I have a covenant to share in my holy blessing.
Oh, God.
The parasite.
I'm sadly.
I'm just teaching him about the birds and the bees.
No, there's that one.
It's okay.
I have my rifle.
I'll just shoot it with my rifle.
Still no, Ashley.
Still no.
ash it's okay you know what i'm happy i don't really want to
see ashley right now do you read me condor one you've been
radio silent for three hours are you all right yeah i'm fine
won't let it happen again and the church i'm still looking
for whatever key i need just trying to see if i can see any
barrels from here i'm glad you're okay roost out all right
nice handgun
Wait, where... What the fuck?
Where are we?
Find the key to the church.
Oh, I'm, like, all the way here.
Hey, there's somebody's hat.
Nice hat.
Hey, that's, like, my hat.
But look at this guy's face again.
Anything in here?
Oh, resources.
Oh, no, that's just the Holy Mary.
Is there a ladder?
No, no ladder.
Hello, everybody.
Oh, it's night time?
Oh, I do not like this.
All right, guys.
We're going to call it here.
Okay.
I think this is a good time to call it after seeing it being
night time.
All right.
Yeah, I was like, you know what?
No.
No, this is a good time to call it there.
We did four hours.
We got a boss fight.
Let's just...
We'll do the other chapter at another time.
It's like, night time?
Oh, it's like, oh, it's the horror part of the horror game?
I'm good.
That's okay.
I think we're...
I think that's a good time to stop now.
Brother, thank you for the Aka Aka Aka Super.
Thank you.
Well, guys.
I hope you guys had a great time for part one.
everybody i had a great time playing uh playing today um
it's great to play resident evil 4 again playing the remake
for the first time um definitely enjoyed it a lot so far i
didn't enjoy the game so far like the controls are less you
know since it's a newer game the controls are definitely
less scuffed it's it's definitely easier to control compared
to the og at resident evil 4 so That's what I like the most.
But yeah, I had a great time.
I hope you guys, I hope you guys enjoyed it too, everybody.
I think I read a lot of super chats coming in, so there
wasn't really much to catch up on.
So I'm going to call it here, because we did do a very long
stream today.
Also, like, Mr. Mad messaged me.
I was like, oh, hey, are you free today?
I was like, I'm streaming.
Mr. Mad messaged me in the middle of my stream.
I was like, hey, are you free right now?
like no i'm streaming they're like okay after the stream we
usually uh wanted to like uh tell you something about
something uh and i was like all right all right anyway guys
um we call here tomorrow is a rest day for me i usually take
sundays off so like usually um unless there's like an event
or a tournament or something on sunday but majority of the
time sunday is my off day um so don't worry like if you're
like oh my god what is your schedule in me like for tomorrow
sunday usually is my rest day anyway everybody um I had a
great time playing part one definitely gonna be doing part
two of Resident Evil 4 I might make a long session for part
2 because it is a 15-hour game So I might do a A longer
session than usual for Resident Evil 4 for Resident Evil 4
part 2 So so I might start at like 1230 or something p.m.
PST I want to do long sessions But anyway guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing And if you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.